Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, ich habe jetzt extra gewartet, mich zu remuten, dass ich schön das Mikrofon hpieße.
Der Müll ist verschluckt.
So, ich habe mal ein Foto von meinem Weinkeller gemacht
Exzellent Weinkeller, das bin ich in meinem Weinkeller und man sieht auch die Heizung dabei
Es wäre nur noch cooler gewesen, wenn ich anstatt die Brille so ein Monocle aufgezogen hätte
Exquisite, exzellent, Weinkeller
Das ist tatsächlich die richtige Heizung
Warum hat Twitch wieder nicht refreshed?
Was ist da los? Moment Leute
Twitch, c'mon brah
Was, was? Jetzt hab ich meinen eigenen Stream geklippt, weil das hier laggt hat
Doch 1080p, 48 fps, stimmt alles, exzellent
Gerade durch Zufall gesehen, dass der Stream on ist
Wahnsinn
So, nachdem wir jetzt ausgiebig meinen Weinkeller begutachtet haben, aber die Zellermusik ist ein bisschen laut gerade
So, ist glaub ich angenehmer
Nachdem wir jetzt ausführlich meinen Weinkeller begutachtet haben und festgestellt haben, dass ich einen ziemlich 3D gerendernden Weinkeller habe
wo irgendwie
nix so wirklich zusammenpasst
von der Decke zur Wandtextur, die scheiße aussieht
noch, dass die Treppe richtigen Schatten wirft
Weiß ich nicht, wer dieses Bild gemacht hat
Es sieht auf jeden Fall verkehrt aus
Exzellent, Weinkeller, exzellent
VR-Keller, ja
Der Kühlschrank hat, das ist kein Kühlschrank, das ist die Heizung
Das ist die Heizung, das sieht echt aus wie ein Kühlschrank
Das ist die Heizung hier
So ein Ding, ich hab jetzt nämlich mal nachgeguckt, was ich für eine Heizung habe
Das ist so eine, realistisch betrachtet sieht das bei mir im Keller eher
eher so aus, ungefähr
Ungefähr so schauts, das ist glaub ich realistischer
Oh, wer weiß was ich da angeklickt hab
Bei mir siehts im Keller eher so aus, das ist
Natürlich, glückliche Familie in der Küche und die Wiesmann-Heizung ist am Start, easy
Oder hier, hier hätten wir auch noch eine
Was sieht man denn hier?
Das ist, ähm
Ah, ah, yes, mein Musikaufnahme, äh, äh, Recording Studio Zimmer ist das hier hinten
Exzellent
Das hatten wir jetzt schon öfters, ähm
Wollen wir hier zu bieten?
Ja, das sieht echt aus wie ein Kühlschrank
Das sieht echt aus wie ein Kühlschrank
Ja, das geht doch auch
Wupp, wupp, wupp
Es gibt jetzt ein Egal-E-Mode im Discord, das hab ich nicht gesehen, also von mir, von mir ist es nicht
Wie bindet man denn den Raspberry Pi an die Heizung an, das kann ich euch mal zeigen
So, also ich hab ja schon mal eine VM gestartet
Oder wie die, wie die coolen Leute bei uns auf der Arbeit sagen, ist meine VM
Man sagt, man sagt ja nicht mal VM, es ist eine VM
Dementsprechend ist sie auch VM-Ware und nicht VM-Ware
VM-Ware
Wenn man Ubuntu auf VM-Ware installiert, dann geht's ab
So, ich zeige euch das hier mal kurz, also hier, ich, ich connecte mich mal auf meinen Raspberry
Im Keller, der natürlich den schönen passenden Namen hat, für den Raspberry im Keller
Ups, vielleicht soll es schon mal rot werden
So, und hier sieht man schon, was ich alles Schönes von der Heizung auslesen kann
Das haben wir uns ja angeguckt, das haben wir ja vorletzten Stream schon gemacht, das kennt ihr ja teilweise schon
Das haben wir ja runde kompiliert, angestöpselt und es funktioniert
Man sieht, dass, ich war eben duschen, das hat der, der warm Wasser ist Temperatur nicht so gut gefallen
Die ist gleich mal getroppt, um 15 Grad
Was nicht sein soll, weil seit gestern spinnt das Ding rum und ich glaube nicht, dass es an mir liegt
Sondern ich glaube irgendwie, entweder liegt es an der Versorgung, an den Startwerk oder von wem auch immer das Gas kommt
Das ist irgendwie zu wenig, irgendwie spackt das rum, weil gestern, weil gestern war der ganzen Tag, war die ganze, war gegen die Heizung den ganzen Tag nicht
Und der Brenner war immer aus, also immer hier auf 0%, jetzt schwankt der ja gerade
Der geht an und aus und an und aus, gestern ging er den ganzen Tag nicht an
Da war das hier teilweise runter auf dauerhaft irgendwie 37 Grad, das war halt viel zu wenig
Und Abgas Temperatur war halt auch, war halt auch weg im Keller
Nee, ich habe mit dem Heizungstyp noch nicht gesprochen, weil jetzt aktuell geht es ja wieder
Aktuell geht es ja wieder, wenn wir jetzt hier lange noch gucken, werden wir sehen, die Abgas Temperaturen der Brenner gehen gleich wieder hoch und die Pumpe pumpt und alles ist gut
Wohlgemerkt, die Heizung zeigt bei nichts davon eine Störung an, deswegen, was wir heute machen werden, ist folgendes
Machen wir mal so einen kleinen Plan und der Chat, der Chat kann sich dann überlegen, was wir zuerst machen wollen
Also, mach das da gerade für Dinger
Ok, es ist fertig
Also, auf dem Raspberry, den mit der Heizung verbunden haben wir ja schon, sieht man hier, funktioniert
Übrigens, man beachtet mal hier diese schönen Sachen hier
Get Temp Abgas, Get WWUWP Nachlauf und solche tollen Sachen
Get Circus Temp und solche Sachen
Also, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig big brain benannt, was die da bei Wiesbaden gemacht haben
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Wiesbaden gemacht wurde oder ob das nur bei dem Softwarehersteller dran liegt, keine Ahnung
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr deutsche Software, weil man Get Error, Na, Get Error 0 ist gut, aber Get Betriebsart oder Get Status Störung ist schon, das muss man erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen
Erstmal Raspberry Pi Upgrade, ne, haben wir ja gemacht und ich mache auch kein Upgrade mehr
Wie verbindet man das mit dem Raspberry Pi? Dafür braucht man sowas hier
USB Kabel, das da braucht man dafür
Sowas da
Guckt und da vorne in der Heizung, man sieht es hier natürlich jetzt wahnsinnig gut
Vorne in der Heizung ist quasi so ein V, so ein Wiesbaden-förmiges Loch, wo man das reinstecken kann
Und dann kann man das mit dem Raspberry verbinden und das Ganze meldet sich am Raspberry Pi an
Das kommt da, hier sieht man es doch schön
Als serielles Interface raus
Soll das eine AB, was?
Ach so, ja das ist so eine halboffizielle AP
Also dieses Interface, das hier, das ist natürlich vom Hersteller, man sieht es ja auch hier, es gibt vom Hersteller offizielle Adapter
Und die haben auch eigene Smart Home Lösung, der Witz ist natürlich, jeder Hersteller macht irgendwas eigenes Smart Home-mäßiges
Und die Dinger sind halt übelst teuer, was man von dem Hersteller offiziell kaufen kann
So und was es jetzt gibt, es gibt auf GitHub ein Projekt, die haben das so ein bisschen reverse-ingeniert, was die Heizung macht
Das ist hier, so
Und das Ding haben wir ja im letzten Stream eingerichtet hier, diesen V-Ctrl-D und das ist das hier
Brich, das ist der Raspberry im Keller, der, guck hier Brenner-Status, der Brenner läuft jetzt, jetzt ist er wieder aus
Immer, bleibt da
Ja, also man sieht es, die Abfragen funktioniert und ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob diese wirre Benamung der Sachen
Ob das eine Sache ist, die an Wiesmann liegt oder eine Sache ist, die an, die an diesem V-Ctrl liegt
Allerdings, ich vermute mal teils, teils, weil sonst kommt niemand auf so abartige Namen wie das da
GetBetriebArtM1
Das muss so eine Mischung sein aus, teilweise heißen die Dinger halt so und deswegen müssen die, die das nachbauen halt auch verwenden
Äh, Topics, oh, das wird mich mal interessieren, das wird mich mal interessieren
So, und deswegen, was wir heute machen müssen, das funktioniert ja, allerdings ist das dann auch ziemlich unsinnig, also man kann damit wenig anfangen
Gestern hat es mir was gebracht, als die Heizung den ganzen Tag nicht ging, da konnte ich immer nachgucken, was die Temperatur macht und alles mögliche
Aber so ist natürlich, das bringt mir natürlich wenig, wenn ich hier zugucken kann, ich bin ja nicht immer auf der Kommando-Zeile eingeloggt
Deswegen machen wir folgende Sachen
Ich muss erst mal in den Chat gucken
Äh, habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Wir machen heute übrigens Essenspause im Stream
Damit wir fertig werden
Ja, wir haben gestern schon zwei Leute gefragt, die das wohl professionell einbauen, ich meine im Chat kann jeder alles behaupten, aber
Die haben sich beide so angehört, als wissen sie wovon sie reden und die konnten mit diesen ganzen Sachen hier nichts anfangen
So, ähm
Du hast schon öfters mal erwähnt, dass du in der Ausbildung nicht wirklich viel gelernt hast, woher hast du dann dein ganzes Wissen im Bereich der Informatik
Ne, das stimmt so nicht, das habe ich glaube ich auch so nicht gesagt, ich habe gesagt, in der Berufsschule lernt man nichts
In der Berufsschule lernt man nichts, also die Berufsschule ist ziemlich für'n Arsch
Da lernt man nichts, ähm
In der Ausbildung sieht man schon was
Und wie gesagt, ich habe ja meine Ausbildung bei einem Provider gemacht
Und da wurde man halt wenig ausgebildet im klassischen Sinne, also sprich, da hat sich kaum mal einer hingesetzt und gesagt, Jungs, heute erkläre ich dir mal den Tag über was
Sondern du hast einfach Dinge gemacht und hast dabei was gelernt
Also ich weiß noch, eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gemacht habe in der Ausbildung war Nagios
Was war da gerade
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was da gerade für eine Nagios Version aktuell war
Gucken wir mal
Manch einer wird jetzt sagen, äh Nagios, äh oder bleibt mir fort
Aber eines der ersten Sachen, die ich, wo ich mich quasi drum kümmern musste in der Ausbildung ohne Abs, ohne irgendeinen Plan von der ganzen Sache zu haben war
Um Nagios und da, wenn man so ins kalte Wasser geworfen wird hast du zwei Möglichkeiten
Entweder du sagst komplett Alter leckt mich und machst gar nichts oder versuchst das halt irgendwie auf die Reihe zu kriegen
Und ich fand das eigentlich so ganz interessant
Haben die irgendwie eine Nagios Release Date, haben die irgendwo eine Übersicht, wann was rausgekommen ist
History of Nagios, ok gucken wir mal, wann die unterschiedliche Version rausgekommen ist
Ne ne ne, so hier so in dem Dreh muss das gewesen sein
Oh, piss dich alle
Nagios-Bot
So in dem Dreh hier muss das ungefähr gewesen sein, weil ich weiß noch, als wir die Ausbildung angefangen haben
Version History, ja gucken wir mal
Ach ne, so weit zurück geht das gar nicht
Zumindest, ich weiß noch, als ich die Ausbildung angefangen habe
Oh, wie spricht man das denn aus?
Lucky Rebel 9?
Wie auch immer, äh Dankeschön auf jeden Fall für den
Sub
Also ursprünglich hatten wir mal eine Nagios 007 oder irgendwie sowas im Einsatz
Das war glaube ich auch nicht mal die 1er Version, die wir ursprünglich hatten, als ich gekommen bin
Und ich habe dann angefangen, ich glaube Nagios 2 war das
Zu installieren und zu administrieren und mir überhaupt mal ein ordentliches
Das als Azubi, der irgendwie gefühlt ein halbes Jahr da war
Auszudenken, wie man das ordentlich aufbauen kann
Viele sagen ja heute, Nagios wäre halt veraltet und kacke und sonst was
Und zum Teil ist das auch so, aber ich muss sagen, dadurch, dass das eines der ersten Sachen war, die ich gemacht habe
Finde ich Nagios immer noch recht angenehm irgendwie, also schwierig
Also man findet irgendwie keine ordentliche Release History
Nagios 2006, was für eine Version gibt es?
Ah hier, hier, ja das kommt hin, genau, ja ja richtig
Also wir hatten noch ursprünglich eine 09er oder 07er oder sowas Nagios
Und ich habe damals dann die 2er, 2er Version von Nagios war neu
Und da haben die einiges an der Config geändert
Man konnte glaube ich dann anfangen irgendwelche Host Templates zu erstellen und zu vererben und sowas
Und damit habe ich dann angefangen das aufzusetzen
Das lief dann auch eine ganze Weile ziemlich gut
Da musste man sich damals, weil es gab so nicht so viel fertige Sachen
Da musste ich mich komplett mit allen Sachen beschäftigen in der Hausbildung, die dazugehört haben
Und Monitoring ist halt ein Thema, das gehört irgendwie zu allem dazu
Also sprich ich musste damals gucken, wie kompiliere ich
Ich hatte keinen Schimmer, ich hatte wirklich keinen Plan
Ich habe mich da über die ganze Zeit abgebrochen
Wie kompiliere ich den Nagios Agent und die Checks mit MySQL Support und Geschiss
Wie kompiliere ich das für, lass mal überlegen, was war das damals
Suze, Redhead und Debian hatten wir glaube ich
Suze, Redhead und Debian
Stack Overflow gab es damals auch nicht
Es gab irgendwelche, es gab IRC gab es noch
IRC und keine Ahnung ob es ihn heute noch gibt
Anscheinend gibt es den Nagios IRC immer noch
Und die Leute waren tatsächlich relativ hilfsbereit
So und das habe ich halt als einer der ersten Sachen in der Ausbildung gemacht
Und das war dann fertig und lief gut
Und dann haben wir irgendwann, haben wir gesagt
Ach brauchen wir nicht mehr, wir nehmen jetzt Zabbix
So und das kann ich euch auch ungefähr sagen, wann das gewesen ist
Weil Zabbix ist ja noch nicht so alt
Zumindest als ich es halt wegen Verbreitung gefunden hatte
Ich glaube so in dem Dreh hier rum
Haben wir dann Zabbix, haben wir dann angefangen auf Zabbix umzustellen
Von Nagios
Ich glaube es war noch vor der 2er Version
Twitch Chat läuft auch noch über IRC
Ich weiß nicht ob der Twitch Chat wirklich über IRC läuft
Aber der Twitch Chat hat einen IRC Interface
Ich habe keine Ahnung ob der intern auch über IRC läuft
Ich weiß es, kein Schimmer
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen tatsächlich, dass es so ist
Weil das im Kern wahrscheinlich einfach geht
Da haben die sich gedacht, warum soll man da was dran ändern
Ja es hat eben einer gefragt, was die
Heißt das Nagios oder NagiOS
Das Nagios
Die große Preisfrage ist, die ich mir immer gestellt habe ist
Was ist die Mehrzahl von Nagios
Das Nagiosse
Ist das Nagii
Nagios
Keine Ahnung
Ich habe da nie eine zufriedenstellende Antwort drauf gefunden
Naga
Nagiosi
Nagiosus
Ich vermute mal in dem Fall ist es ganz einfach, dass beides Nagios heißt
Und das war eines der ersten Sachen die ich gemacht habe
So viel dazu
Irgendjemand hat gefragt gerade, was die
Was eine moderne Alternative dazu ist
Ich finde die Frage gerade nicht mehr
Ah hier
GPOP, was wäre denn die moderne Alternative
Es gibt mittlerweile ziemlich viel
Oh guck mal, Michael 50 Billiarden ist am Start
Es gibt mittlerweile viele Sachen, das wichtigste was man sich heute beim Thema Monitoring
Das ist ja so die
So der Überbegriff von dieser ganzen Geschichte
Es gibt relativ viel
Man muss sich erstmal fragen, was will man denn machen
Nagios beziehungsweise Zappix
Das ist so die klassische
Das klassische checkbasierte Monitoring
Also sprich man hat irgendwo einen zentralen Server
Mit vielleicht ein paar Agents oder so
Aber in der Regel einen zentralen Server
Der wiederum auf die Systeme geht
Und dort guckt, sind Ports auf
Oder sich einloggt auf den System
Und einen Agent anstößt, der irgendwelche checks ausführt
Also quasi von einer zentralen Stelle
Ohne jetzt Details zu wissen, was da eigentlich genau passiert auf dem Server
Zu gucken, sind Sachen da
Oder sind Sachen gestartet oder sind Sachen ab
Das ist so mit Zappix und Nagios
Das ist so die klassische checkbasierte Monitoring Geschichte
Mittlerweile gibt es aber
Es gibt eigentlich drei Trends
Das erste ist
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so die 100% korrekten Begriffe sind
Weil ich glaube, es gibt gar keine richtig korrekten Begriffe dafür
Das erste, was es aktuell so gibt, ist so
Event-Log-Monitoring, nenne ich das mal
Das ist so der Bereich
Nicht Event-Log, da kommt
Da kommt Windows-Zeug
Das ist so der Bereich von Elasticsearch
Und was gibt es dann sonst noch?
Logs-Dash, Elasticsearch, Kibana und Gedöns
Also sprich, das ist das, wo man weiß
Wo man sich anguckt, was ist denn der Output von irgendwelchen Anwendungen
Oder beziehungsweise, was machen die Anwendungen gerade genau
Ja, das ist eines der Sachen dafür
Das würde ich mal so als Event-Monitoring, beziehungsweise Log-Überwachung und sonst was bezeichnen
Das ist das eine
Wir können uns bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal angucken, was die Liste dazu sagt
Das nächste ist, was es da noch gibt, ist
Metric-basiertes Monitoring
Sprich, das ist in die Anwendung eingebaut
Das machen wir heute übrigens auch
Eine der Sachen davon ist Prometheus
Und Prometheus ist so eine Mischung aus dem klassischen Monitoring
Wo man von einem Host auf alle Sachen, die man checken muss, zugreift
Und man hat mehr Informationen über die Anwendung
Sprich, wenn ich jetzt einsammeln möchte
Wie oft mein Garbage-Collector in Java läuft oder so
Oder wenn ich wissen will, welche internen Counter in meiner Anwendung
Irgendeinen Wert haben oder sowas
Dann gibt es für so ziemlich jede Programmiersprache Prometheus, Bindings
Oder schon fertige Exporter, die das bereitstellen
Und da habe ich mehr Informationen zu
Und das dritte ist, wie gesagt, das klassische checkbasierte Monitoring
Eins ist nicht unbedingt besser als das andere in dem Fall
Es kommt darauf an, was man machen will
Deswegen würde ich sagen, die moderne Alternative zu Nagios ist Zabbix
Wenn man einfach was will, was geht, was man installiert
Und was dann alles macht, was man machen will
Würde ich sagen, kann man Zabbix gut nehmen
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied von Grafana und Prometheus?
Das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nicht so viel zu tun
Prometheus ist die Datenbank und das Einsammeln von Metriken
Grafana ist die Oberfläche, die da aus den Daten was Ansehnliches macht
Ein bisschen was ist in Prometheus selbst eingebaut
Aber richtig schön kann man das so mit Grafana machen
Also Prometheus ist die Datenbank und quasi der Teil, der die Sachen speichert
Und die Sachen einsammelt
Und Grafana ist das obendrauf, was die Sachen ordentlich anzeigt, die man eingesammelt hat
Bei Prometheus gibt es noch ein paar Alternativen dazu
Es gibt Prometheus, dann gibt es noch die Geschichte von InfluxDB
Das ist dann der sogenannte Tickstack
Die Dinger haben alle immer super Namen
Das ist so eine Mischung quasi aus einem Tool, was Daten einsammelt
Eine Datenbank und eine Oberfläche und irgendein Alertmanager oder was das andere ist
Was beim Thema Monitoring noch wichtig ist, ist nach welchem Modell man das Ganze machen will
Also sprich, möchte man von einem zentralen Server zugreifen und quasi die Metriken abziehen
Oder möchte man, dass alle verteilten Server die Metriken zu einem zentralen System schicken
So, die zwei unterschiedlichen Sachen gibt es da
Prometheus ist Pull und InfluxDB Tick ist Push
Drum gedreht? Ne, ne, ne, passt, genau
So ist das
So, was gibt es denn hier bei der Monitoring?
Diese Liste hier ist übrigens wirklich gut
Die hat auch nicht umsonst so viele Einträge
Es gibt ja jede Menge solcher, es gibt auch eine Awesome List of Awesome Lists
Wir können ja mal kurz durchscrollen
Hallo, warum geht er jetzt nicht runter?
Warum geht er jetzt nicht runter dazu?
Ah, jetzt, ah, yes, excellent
Ähm, habt ihr auf der Arbeit zufällig mit Seam zu tun?
Überleg gerade, was das, was das, sagt mir jetzt nichts, ne
Oh, ich hab grad hier mal geguckt, was das ist
Security Information and Event Management, die zwei Komplarblatt
Ne, ne
Äh, was auch immer dahinter sich verbirgt
Oh, ich wollt doch grad zum Thema Monitoring
Hallo, warum geht das jetzt nicht runter?
So, also, was gibt es denn hier Schönes?
Äh, Nagios Gedöns, Nagios ist immer noch ziemlich, ziemlich verbreitet
Einfach weil es Nagios schon ewig gibt
Alerta, das hatte ich mir auch mal kurz angeguckt
Das ist eher was, was, was ziemlich, genau, irgendwas Simples gewesen
Äh, Cacti, Leute, das ist zwar nicht mehr angesagt
Aber Cacti war mal früher so 2007 rum
2008, 19, der Shit, was Netzwerkdarstellung anbelangt hat
Guckt euch das mal an, da kriegt ihr Anfälle, wenn ihr das heute seht
Aber davon abgesehen, dass die Seite irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert
Worauf hast du eigentlich Home Assistant laufen? Auf einem Vierkern Pentium
Wie heißen die Dinger?
Silver Lake? Nee, ähm
Auf so einem da
Auf so einem, Gmini Lake, nicht Silver Lake
Auf so einem Vierkern Ding
Ja, also, wer das vielleicht, wer das vielleicht noch kennt, ja
Also, so sah Cacti aus
Einmal hatte das Ding natürlich so wahnsinnig Big Brain Crafts
Aber das, was Cacti eigentlich cool gemacht hat, war eher das da
Sowas da
Und da hat man sich damals richtig krass gefühlt, wenn man solche, wenn man solche Netzwerkdiagramme von seinem Netzwerk hat
Da kam er sich cool vor, ja
Ich weiß nicht, wenn man sich überlegen, 2007 war das wirklich der Hit, ja
Du konntest nämlich, das ist heute immer noch nicht schlecht in dem Sinn
Im Kern, das, was es macht, macht es eigentlich ganz gut
Ähm, du kannst die Übersicht von deinen Netzwerkgeräten machen
Und dann gehst du halt drüber und siehst dann Auslastungen, Interface Up, Down und solche Geschichten
Aber, aber sag mal so, Cacti, er hat schon so
Ja, genau, so sah das aus, so sah das aus
Gibt es da noch vielleicht eine Demo online?
Ja
Ja, es wird übrigens immer noch aktiv, aktiv maintained
Was man sagen muss, damals waren fast alle Web-Anwendungen auf PHP-Basis
Ich meine, die Seite sieht halt aus, wie als wäre sie 2005 stehen geblieben
Ja, ähm, ich kann euch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sagen, was jetzt die moderne Alternative zu Cacti ist
Das integriert sich halt heute in umfangreichere Monitoring-Systeme
Aber so reines Netzwerk-Monitoring fällt mir als Cacti-Alternative gar nichts großartig ein
Und man sieht, es gibt jede Menge Monitoring-Lösungen für groß und kleine Sachen
Es gibt auch so ein paar ganz, ganz easy-Dinger, die man vielleicht für daheim verwenden kann
Aber ich bin mittlerweile zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es zwei Systeme gibt, die einem out of the box ziemlich, ziemlich viel liefern
Und man auch nicht allzu viel konfigurieren muss
Das ist einmal für die klassische Monitoring-Geschichte Zappix und dann die Prometheus-Grafana-Kombi
Da muss man bei beiden Sachen nicht viel machen und man hat sau viele Funktionen eingebaut
Da muss ich ein bisschen an die Bedienung gewöhnen bei Zappix, weil das Web-Interface von Zappix ist wirklich der Teufel
Aber es funktioniert
Damals, ja die meisten Anwendungen, die heute neu entstehen, würde ich sagen, sind nicht unbedingt in PHP
Viele Anwendungen, die heute neu entstehen, was Web-Geschichten gerade im Server umfällt, ist ganz viel in Go mittlerweile
Genau, achja, das muss man auch sagen, Nagios hat 30 Milliarden Forks
Also sehr viele, also die Hälfte der Systeme, die in dieser Monitoring-Liste drin standen, waren mal ursprünglich Nagios Forks
Checkmk war ursprünglich, glaube ich, ein Nagios Fork
Libre, Dings, NMS, nee, Open NMS-Gedöns war irgendwie mal Nagios Fork
Icinga war mal ein Nagios, alles, alles, oder Icinga, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig ausspricht, war alles mal Nagios Fork
Ursprünglich, ursprünglich
So, und jetzt zum eigentlichen, zum eigentlichen Sachen zu kommen, was wir heute machen, ist
Also als erstes müssen wir uns mal zum Testen ein Prometheus plus Grafana installieren
Das ist schneller gemacht, als ich es fast hier geschrieben habe, wir basteln uns ein Docker-Compose-File und starten das und dann läuft's
Das ist easy, ja, also wir brauchen ein Prometheus und Grafana zum Üben
Zum, was heißt zum Üben, zum, ja zum Üben bevor ich das auf meine richtige Kiste installiere
Und, ähm, übrigens keine Frametrops heute her, heute schon mal, huge, ähm, ja Tommy, kann ich gleich machen
Und, äh, das brauchen wir nämlich für die Darstellung von den Heizungswerten am Ende
So, dann machen wir ein.NET Programm, was die, also eine Runde Proggers, was sich connectet zu dem Demon, der hier auf dem Raspberry Pi läuft, dort wo das Kabel zur Heizung dran ist
Und, äh, Informationen abfragt, plus, äh, Prometheus, Prometheus, Metrix, Export, also sprich, das Programm startet, fragt vom Raspberry Pi Werte von der Heizung ab und unter slash Metrix kann man das dann abrufen
So, ähm, was ist denn das dritte, was wir machen müssen, ich Poggers, Proggers
Ähm, ich glaube das war's
Die zwei, Raspberry Pi Update, da gibt's nichts mehr zu updaten, das haben wir doch letztens erst gemacht, was für eine Heizung hast du, ich hab eine Vito Dens 222
Also Leute, ich würd euch mal, ich würd vorstellen, wir fangen mal damit an, das ist relativ einfach, dann haben wir zumindest das Ganze schon mal laufen
Ähm, ich lock mich hier mal wieder aus, dann haben wir das Ganze, da haben wir das Ganze zumindest schon mal laufen
Das ist aber auch, das ist relativ schnell gemacht, das heißt wir legen, achso, ich sollte noch was zu Docker und Docker Compose erzählen, äh, Docker ist ein Frontend für Linux Container
Es ist bei weitem nicht mehr das einzige und Docker ist auf dem absteigenden Ast in letzter Zeit, dadurch, dass Docker Inc, ähm, also die Firma hinter Docker hat, ähm, quasi, nicht wirklich Docker verkauft, aber die Enterprise Sparte von Docker verkauft
Und, ähm, das ist auch schon ein bisschen her, irgendwie ein paar Monate, allerdings, das Format an sich unten drunter, also sprich dieses Docker Container Format, das verwenden saumäßig viele
Es gibt alternative Implementierungen mittlerweile, sowas wie Podman von Red Hat, aber, ähm, im Prinzip sind das alles nur Frontends für die Container Funktion im Linux Kernel
Und das gibt es in einfach, sowas wie Docker und das gibt es in kompliziert mit Orchestrierung und HA und Load Balancing und Geschiss drum herum mit Kubernetes
Und 30 Billiardensachen, das Container Ökosystem ist mittlerweile so unübersichtlich, dass ich da nicht mehr durchblicke
So, und ein Trend, den ich beobachte, den ich ein bisschen fragwürdig finde, ist, wenn man hier mal auf Reddit guckt, zum Beispiel bei Self Hosted oder so, eben, äh, auf Reddit, das lese ich ab und zu mal ganz gern, was es denn für neue Software gibt und was die Leute gerade aktuell so einsetzen
Ähm, ein Trend, den ich da ein bisschen fragwürdig finde, ist, Moment Leute, ich muss mal kurz Reddit umschalten, das neue Reddit geht mir immer auf den Keks, wenn ich das sehe, ah, yes, excellent
Wobei, es ist auch nicht wirklich besser, am besten, also eigentlich ist immer noch Klassik, aber das neue Reddit hat auch schon so seine, seine Tücken
So, und was ich hier ein bisschen, ähm, fragwürdig finde, ist, also die meisten Leute lassen mittlerweile alles, was sie so haben, auf Docker laufen
Und, ähm, Kubernetes und solche Sachen setzen sich da auch immer mehr im Heimbereich durch, die Sache ist plus die
Dadurch, dass es jetzt quasi als das neue Alheilmittel verkauft wird, so nach dem Motto, einmal Kubernetes installiert, sich nie wieder um seine Infrastruktur kümmern müssen, das ist ja kom, ist ja kompletter Blödsinn, ja
Ähm, damit man Kubernetes überhaupt gescheit verwenden kann, es geht nicht darum, dass man das überhaupt installieren kann, installieren gibt es ja auch verschiedene Sachen, um das einfacher zu machen, Minikube und was es nicht alles gibt
Aber, dass man das ordentlich verwenden kann, dann bringt das gar nichts, wenn ich mir da einen Raspberry Pi daheim hinstelle und da jetzt irgendwie Kubernetes draufinstalle, das ist komplett, komplett hängen geblieben
Also, wozu, das macht es jetzt auch nicht irgendwie ausfallsicherer oder besser oder eben, irgendwas, ja
Ähm, und was ich da ein bisschen bedenklich finde, ist, dass das so verkauft wird, als nimmst du Kubernetes, hast du nie wieder Probleme, das ist ja nicht so
Was, ähm, das Problem daran ist, für mich, also wie ich das, wie ich das hier so sehe, dass halt Leute, die quasi schon erst anfangen mit diesem Thema, sich da quasi nicht nur drum kümmern müssen und überlegen müssen
Okay, was brauche ich denn daheim alles, also keine Ahnung, brauche ich einen Mailserver, brauche ich einen Wiki, brauche ich einen Fileserver, was brauche ich denn alles
Und vielleicht sich damit ein bisschen mit den einzelnen Diensten zu beschäftigen und gut ist, kriegen die jetzt erstmal vor den Latz geklatscht, Kubernetes
Und man handelt sich damit, vor allem im Heimbereich, wenn man nur nur ein kleines Setup hat, so viel unnötige Komplexität ein, die ich gar nicht für, für, also nicht für notwendig halte
Und ich finde, das wiegt auch den Vorteil überhaupt nicht auf
Wenn da mal was nicht geht, da bist du nicht damit beschäftigt zu gucken, warum was nicht geht, sondern wie du dann Kubernetes wieder an den Start kriegst
Das habe ich auf der Arbeit schon auch oft genug gesehen
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, ich arbeite bei einer größeren Firma und wir haben mit Sicherheit keine blöden Leute bei uns und es gibt mittlerweile auch relativ viele Ressourcen, was Kubernetes und alles angeht
Und sogar wir hatten schon öfters Probleme, die auf entweder, weil es die Leute nicht richtig kapiert haben, weil es zu komplex ist, Probleme zurückzuführen waren oder weil Kubernetes komische Kubernetes-Dinger gemacht hat
Das selbst zu betreiben ist also auch im Enterprise-Umfeld gar nicht ohne
Und im Heimbereich ist es komplett sinnlos
Eines der größten Vorteile, die man durch sowas wie Kubernetes hat, ist, mal gucken, ob es da ein schönes Build zugibt
Echt wirklich
Eines der größten Vorteile, die man durch solche Dinge wie Kubernetes hat, ist, wenn man jetzt einen Web-Service betreibt, also sprich, irgendeine Web-Anwendung
Die sich gut dafür eignet, parallelisiert zu arbeiten
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine, was nehmen wir da jetzt mal, was gibt es da für eine schöne, wenn man sowas wie YouTube hat zum Beispiel und es laden ganz viele Leute Videos hoch, also sprich, ich habe genug Bandbreite und alles, es laden ganz viele Leute Videos hoch und ich muss die Videos verarbeiten und dann irgendwas machen mit den Videos
Das ist relativ gut parallelisierbar, weil ein Video ist ein Video und das interessiert sich für das andere Video nicht, also sprich, das Video, was User A hochlädt, hat mit dem Video von User B überhaupt nichts zu tun
Also und jetzt ist es Sonntagabend und die Leute wollen alle ihre Videos hochladen
Früher war das ein bisschen problematisch, da musstest du gucken, ok, was brauche ich denn maximaler Leistung und musstest du das irgendwie hinstellen
Das ist mit einer Umgebung, also mit einer ordentlich ausreichenden, dimensionellen Infrastruktur und mit Container, nicht Virtualisierung, Container Orchestrierung ist das einfacher
Da kann ich zum Beispiel sagen, ok, ich stelle fest, meine Load geht hoch, ich starte jetzt einfach noch 26 Video Render Container und gut ist
Natürlich muss es die Hardware unten drunter auch hergeben und das ist ziemlich einfach, aber das komplizierte ist und das hat glaube ich eben im Chat auch jemand gesagt
Der Tro-M, das komplizierte daran ist, dass die Sache, die man in den Containern laufen lässt, gut parallel funktioniert
Und wenn man eine uralte Legacy Anwendung hat und man packt die in einen Container und lässt den dann auf Kubernetes laufen, wird die Sache nicht unbedingt besser durch
Man kann vielleicht ein paar Probleme aus dem Weg gehen, dass man beispielsweise keine uralt Betriebssysteme auch vielleicht uralt Hardware betreiben muss, aber im Kern geht das Problem nicht weg dadurch
Und ich glaube so richtig gut ist die ganze Kubernetes Geschichte auch nur, wenn du die Infrastruktur gar nicht bei dir betreibst, sondern irgendwo in der Cloud
Also zum Beispiel dieses, wie heißt es nochmal, nicht AWS, AKS, Azure, genau AKS
Also wenn man zum Beispiel das fix und fertig als Service kauft bei Azure, dann hat man tatsächlich die Vorteile, dass man sich um relativ wenig kümmern muss
Natürlich man muss den Scheiß bezahlen, ob das viel billiger wird als das bei sich lokal laufen zu lassen, weiß ich nicht
Du brauchst halt weniger Leute vor Ort, vielleicht rechnet es sich dann dadurch, aber man muss sich die ganze Sache wie bei vielen Techniken genau angucken
Und jetzt im Heimbereich zu sagen, irgendwie Kubernetes Beste ist Blödsinn
Ich bin ein PP-Ger und verstehe gar nichts, ja was soll ich sagen
Ich gebe zu, das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Confuse, aber das Thema ist auch ziemlich ziemlich komplex
So wir fangen jetzt mal an, also das erste was wir machen ist, wir installieren uns mal eine Kombination aus Prometheus und Grafana
Das ist ziemlich einfach, wir installieren uns das lokal auf meiner VM im Container, um das Ganze auszuprobieren
Wir machen mal ein Docker-Compose-File, habe ich Docker-Compose überhaupt installiert? Hab ich, sehr gut
So und Docker-Compose ist so die ganz ganz light Variante von, nennen wir es mal Container-Orchestrierung
Also sprich, man macht eine Config-Datei, da schreibt man rein, was der alle starten soll und wie das zusammenhängt
Und sagt Docker-Compose ab und da startet alles für ein
Also ihr werdet es gleich sehen, was man dazu braucht ist, Docker installiert und Docker-Compose installiert
Und Docker ist ein Frontend für Linux-Container
Also Linux-Container an sich, die eigentliche Technik, die ist im Linux-Kernel drinne
Und egal was man verwendet, ob Docker, Potman, Kubernetes, was gibt es dann sonst noch, Rancher, CoreOS
Ach da gibt es, es gibt Milliarden Sachen mittlerweile, was Containerverwaltung angeht
Das sind alles im Prinzip Frontends und Aufsätze
Die eigentliche Sache, die man braucht, um Container betreiben zu können, ist im Linux-Kernel drin
Und das ist eine Mischung aus Cgroups, Namespaces und
Das dritte vermetz gar nicht ein
Namespaces, Cgroups und, mag mir nicht, keine Ahnung
Wie dem auch sei, das sind die Sachen, die im Linux-Kernel drin sind
Und da drauf basiert alles, im Endeffekt
Und noch mal kurz gesagt, der große Unterschied zu einer VM, also von Container zu einer VM
Der große Unterschied ist, dass eine VM quasi die komplette Hardware nachbaut
Und du musst ein eigenes Betriebssystem installieren, in der VM
Und du musst die ganze Hardware nachbauen
Und für alles, was in der VM läuft, sieht das so aus, als wäre das ein eigener Rechner
Wohingegen, in einem Container ist das ein bisschen anders
Ein Container ist nach wie vor ein ganz normaler Prozess
Der, also ein x-beliebiger Prozess, so wie alle anderen hier auch
So wie Firefox hier zum Beispiel
Der auf meinem Server läuft, bzw. auf meinem Desktop, auf meinem Host
Mit dem gleichen Kernel unten drunter, wie alle anderen Prozesse auch
Warum kein Vacrant mit Puppet? Das kann man auch machen
Das ist dann aber eher was in Richtung VM
Cube 17
Dankeschön, zwei Monate
So, das ist eigentlich der große Unterschied
Das heißt natürlich auch, dass man theoretisch
Weil man muss sagen, dass CPU-Performance in VMs eigentlich kaum einen Unterschied macht noch
Aber was RAM-Auslastung und Plattenbelegung und sowas angeht
Sind Container natürlich deutlich, deutlich leichtgewichtiger als komplette VMs
Ist ja auch logisch, in der VM läuft ein komplettes Betriebssystem und alles nochmals
Der emuliert die Hardware, der braucht ein komplettes Betriebssystem, braucht ordentliche RAM
Und es muss alles nochmal neu installiert werden drin
In einem Container ist das nicht so
Ein Container ist im Prinzip ein ganz stinknormaler Prozess
Auf meinem Server drauf, mit ein bisschen Sandbox drum um
Gibt es OpenVZ noch? Ja, OpenVZ gibt es noch
Und bei vielen Hostern wird auch immer noch OpenVZ eingesetzt
Das heißt, man kann ja auch noch ein paar Prozesse machen
Bei vielen Hostern wird auch immer noch OpenVZ eingesetzt
Weil in den vergangenen Jahren die Isolierung, was bei Docker-Containern da an Isolierung existiert
Wohl noch nicht so das wahre ist
Mittlerweile weiß ich nicht, wie da die Verbreitung ist
Aber ich denke, dass auch heute noch viele Hoster OpenVZ einsetzen
Der LXC hat ja die gleichen Probleme
Aber OpenVZ hat es, glaube ich, nie in den Körnern geschafft
OpenVZ ist so quasi die ursprüngliche Containergeschichte
Doch bevor es LXC und sowas gab, dann lieber KVM
Das ist aber was ganz anderes
OpenVZ ist quasi eher was Richtung Container, als was Richtung VM
Wird bei LXC dann auch nur ein Prozess genutzt oder wie in einer VM die Hardware?
LXC, Docker, Kubernetes, sonst was, die verwenden alles das Gleiche
Nämlich die Sachen, die im Dienungskörner drin sind
Also sprich, LXC, Docker, Kubernetes, alles das Gleiche
Also sprich, Cgroups und Namespaces
Dementsprechend ist das genau das Gleiche
Wenn du mit LXC was startest, läuft das genauso auf dem Host drauf
Wie mit Docker oder mit Kubernetes
Da ist überhaupt kein Unterschied
Deswegen kann man ja auch, das ist immer, wo man es am besten dran sieht
Deswegen kann man ja auch in einer VM neue Kernel-Module laden
Weil in einer VM ein komplett eigenes Linux nochmal installiert ist
Und auch komplett nochmal drauf läuft
Unabhängig vom Hostbetriebssystem
Und in einem Docker-Container oder generell in einem Linux-Container
Kann ich kein Kernel-Modul laden, unabhängig voneinander
Also sprich, ich kann zwar ein Kernel-Modul laden, aber dann ist das für alle da
Weil sich alle Prozesse in den gleichen Kernel teilen
Logischerweise, was auch sonst, das gibt ja nichts, kann sich vielleicht zwei Sachen parallel laufen lassen
Money, 380 Cent
Halber Döner-Teller schon mal am Start
Ach nee, im Moment, das waren ja keine Bits
Das waren ja nur Channel-Points
Dann doch kein Döner am Start
Pepehands, was mach ich denn jetzt die Woche?
Ich muss was essen Leute, ich muss doch was essen
Ich muss was essen, ich muss mal in Internetrechnungen bezahlen
Was mach ich nur?
Ich könnte jetzt ja noch so Beauty-Influencer-mäßig anfangen halb zu heulen
So nach dem Motto, Leute ihr seid mir so unglaublich wichtig
Was würd ich nur ohne meine Fans machen im Chat?
Aber Leute, was mach ich, ich wäre nichts ohne euch
Man kennt das ja, Q-Chat
Irgendwer muss für die doppelte Abrechnung aufkommen
So, ich hab jetzt ganz schön lange geschwätzt
Wie lange hab ich denn jetzt erzählt?
48 Minuten ohne auch nur eine Sache zu schreiben
Huge, Big Brain
Also, wir machen das jetzt mal ganz schnell
Ich, äh...
Guck mal, warte mal, also Version, wie ging das noch?
Version 3 haben wir noch glaube ich Anfangsscheißbron
Docker, Compose, Example, ich muss mir das mal abgucken
Das krieg ich immer aus dem Kopf nicht hin, blablabla
Da, ah, genau, easy
Wunderbar, so
Äh, also Services, den Scheiß hier brauchen wir nicht
Das wird jetzt bloß, bloß dass ich was zum abgucken habe
Äh...
So, machen wir weg
Also, wir brauchen als Service einmal ein Prometheus
So, und da brauchen wir ein Image
Docker, Hub, Prometheus, was gibt's da für ein Image?
Prom, Prom Prometheus
Ich bin jetzt an nichts besseres eingefallen, oder?
Was da brauchen wir?
Image
So, Ports bei Prometheus, die weiß ich, die sind 90, 90
90, 90, ups, 90, 90
Ok, und dann brauchen wir noch, das reicht jetzt schon
Dann brauchen wir noch ein Grafana
Docker, Hub, Grafana
Warum hast du kein egal Emote?
Gute Frage, könnte ich machen
Zeig mal, gibt's da ein gutes?
Oh, nice
Moment, Moment Leute, ich mach das, ich mach das grad mal rein
Ich muss das aber bei FFZ machen, weil FFZ aktualisiert schneller
Äh, äh, äh, äh
Moment Leute, ich mach kurz, ich mach kurz das egal Emote rein
Ganz, ganz huge, important, wichtig
Emotes, public
Egal
Ach nee, bei FFZ gibt's das nicht
Fuck, ok, add, add to channel
Huge
Also, wir haben ein egal Emote
Das könnte aber kurz dauern, bis das drinne ist
Guck mal, geht das Emote schon?
Noch nicht, also es ist drinne, es ist auf jeden Fall drinne
Aber das kann ein bisschen dauern, bis das funktioniert, bis das gesüngt hat
Nee, der Chat checkt es ja auch nicht
Welche Distro ist das? Das ist Manjaro mit die 3WM
So, jetzt brauchen wir einen Grafana, da brauchen wir noch hier den passenden
Jawoll, wunderbar, hier, Image
Äh, Image
Ich glaub, die Quotes kann man sogar weglassen
So, äh, Grafana Image brauchen wir, dann ähm
Brauchen wir hier, müssen wir was sagen, Ports
Grafana ist auf 3000
3000, 3000
So
Das war's, mehr müssen wir nicht machen
Wenn ich jetzt nicht was vergessen hab, hab ich was vergessen
Ich glaub, das war's
So, und deswegen ist das mit Docker Compose ganz praktisch
Ähm, wenn ich hier quasi einmal meine, meine, meine Config und Dienste und wie die zusammengehören angegeben hab
Kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, Docker Compose, ich hoffe, ich hab mich nicht verschrieben
Datenbank, Gott
Das muss nicht Persistent sein, großartig, das kann er aufs Filesystem schreiben
Ähm, kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, Docker Compose ab, und wenn ich mich nicht verschrieben hab, sollte er jetzt
Oh, ich muss die Dinger noch verbinden, sonst kann ich von dem einen nicht auf den anderen zugreifen
Hab ich auch vergessen
Egal, ich zeig euch mal
So, das war's, mehr muss man nicht machen
Und jetzt, wenn ich jetzt auf Localhost Port 3000 geh, sollte da ein Grafana laufen
Und, da läuft ein Grafana
Admin, Admin, Bam, Don't Save, neues Passwort, 123456, 123456
Und schon, aber ein Grafana laufen
Und das ist halt recht
Easy as fuck
Die können sich gegenseitig ansprechen, aber nicht, wenn ich die nicht verbunden habe
Passwort liegt, oh nein
Geht das Wendler ihm auch schon
So, ähm
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert, wahrscheinlich funktioniert das, wenn ich die IP vom Haus nehme, eventuell
Müssen wir mal gucken, aber eleganter wäre es, wenn ich direkt sage, dass ein Container aufs andere zugreifen darf
Dann kann ich es nämlich mit dem Containernamen machen
So, ähm, gucken wir mal, add data source, Prometheus
Also das wird nicht funktionieren, weil Localhost ist jetzt ja nicht mein Localhost hier der Desktop, sondern die, der Container
Und das funktioniert nicht, kann ich so mitmachen
Oh, easy
Das ist ja einfach, man muss die Dinger gar nicht verlinken
Ich dachte man muss noch reinschreiben Links to oder irgendwie sowas, aber so ist ja auch gut
Wunderbar
So, jetzt können wir uns ein Dashboard anlegen
Ja, DDoS mal schön Localhost, Leute
So, jetzt können wir uns ein neues Dashboard anlegen, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, add query, Prometheus, ähm, irgendwas
Uptime oder so, up
Ne, wie heißen die
Host ab, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, wie heißt denn nochmal das Prometheus Uptime Zeug
Ach ja, man kann übrigens hier auch selbst gucken auf Localhost 9090 slash metrics
Dann sieht man alles, was standardmäßig so ein Prometheus schon an Daten exportiert, ähm, was er quasi standardmäßig mitbringt
Und das ist wirklich ganz praktisch
Und hier sieht man halt auch schön den Unterschied zu dem klassischen checkbasierten Monitoring
In dem klassischen checkbasierten Monitoring würde ich sagen, hier, ähm, schau mal nach, ähm, ob der Server läuft
Oder schau mal nach, ob der Arbeitsspeicher ausgelastet ist, mehr als drei Gigabyte
Und hier habe ich halt Informationen drüber, was die Anwendung macht, so nach dem Beispiel, was der Garbage Collector macht
Ähm, irgendwelche Dinger, wo ich nicht mal weiß, was es ist, irgendwelche IP Tables, Tracking, Gedöns
Ähm, wie war denn die, wie war denn für Prometheus nochmal die Uptime
Die Mode geht? Wahnsinn
War es einfach nur ab? War es einfach nur ab?
Ne, ne, worüber läuft das E-Mode? Ähm, bei der Twitch-TV jetzt
Aber zum Beispiel, was wir machen können ist, wir können hier irgendwie sowas nehmen, was da exportiert wird und uns das hier anzeigen lassen
Das sind jetzt Sachen, die sind relativ, relativ sinnlos, stell das jetzt mal runter auf die letzten fünf Minuten
Weil der Standard Prometheus nichts exportiert, was uns interessiert
Alle wurden gebaitet
Aber so sieht es im Endeffekt aus, wenn man da sinnvolle Metriken importiert
Und das Ziel ist jetzt, dass wir was programmieren, was sich verbindet zu dem Raspberry Pi im Keller
Informationen von der Heizung abfragt
Hast du Home Assistant auch gedockert? Ja, allerdings die offizielle Variante von denen
Nicht mit eigenem Docker Composer
Und das Ziel ist, dass wir hier die Werte von der Heizung reinkriegen
Deswegen stoppen wir das Ganze jetzt mal
Löschen das wieder, jetzt ist nämlich wieder alles weg
Das ist übrigens auch ein riesen Vorteil von dieser ganzen Container-Geschichte
Die beiden Anwendungen sind jetzt rückstandslos quasi vom System POD
Im Gegensatz zu, ich würde es hier irgendwie über den Paketmanager installieren
Ich kann natürlich aus, ich könnte wahrscheinlich auch hier irgendwie Grafana drüber installieren oder so
Aber dann hätte ich den ganzen Grad nur Überreste drauf
Und für solche Sachen zum ausprobieren und testen ist die Container richtig gut
So, wir müssen jetzt mal unsere IDE starten
Musik zu laut oder geht's? Müsste eigentlich halbwegs passen
So, machen wir ein neues Projekt
Wie nennen wir das Ganze jetzt mal?
Tritzen ist ein Paketmanager, also ein User Depot Manager
Wir brauchen einen guten Programm-Name für das Ding, Leute
Wir brauchen einen guten Programm-Name für das Ding zum Heizung abfragen
Einen kleinen Tick minimal lauter, ja, denke ich auch
Ähm, minimal leiser
Heizor, Console Application 14, das finde ich auch gut
Heizor
Das sieht schon ganz schön dumm aus
Der Heizor, Alter
Ähm
Ich kann es auch einfach Aja-Ja nennen
Wärmewändler
Das O muss eine Null werden, hab ich doch schon
Heizor, das ist eine O, das ist eine Null
Wärm, nee, nee, keine Sonderzeichen
Okay, ich nenne es irgendwie ganz
Cute Chat
Hitzewändler
So, das nennen wir jetzt so
Reicht
Es muss irgendwie heißen
Ich check das dann eh später mal mir ein
Und dann wollte ich halt eine Description dabei schreiben, was es denn eigentlich ist
Heizor, Export-Tier
Das ist eigentlich, das ist eigentlich richtig gut Florian
Weil, dann weiß ich wenigstens, dass es ein Prometheus-Exporter ist
Heizor, Export-Tier
Das ist doch mal was, Cute Heizung
Findest du deine Programme, ja finde ich, weil ich check die alle ins Git ein und push das dann zu einem
Zentralen Server bei mir
Das ist ja richtig, Sixhead ist das
Da reicht der normale Kopf schon nicht für, der ist schon doppelt breit
Okay, Create
Na ist das schon fertig rödeln, ging aber
Das ging aber jetzt echt sehr zackig
Muss mal kurz checken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert gerade
Ja, gut, klappt alles
Sehr nice
Dann fangen wir mal an mit dem Heizer-Exporter
Eine Sache, die ich noch einstellen muss ist
Wo stellt man den Kram noch ein, ich will nur zwei Leerzeichen
Spaces
Oh warte, wo ist das versteckt, das finde ich immer nicht
Irgendwo hier
Ja, hier
So, Spaces und ich will zwei Spaces haben
Zwei Spaces
Welche Server soll ich benutzen, das da
Äh, passt
Das da
Fasching, nee, geh mal weg, was unten rechts
Ah, kann man das hier
Intensize Format, genau, ah jetzt, zwei
Zwei, save
Und jetzt
Macht er das nicht, oder
Wie kann, kann ich den jetzt reformaten lassen irgendwie
Wie lasse ich den jetzt reformaten
Reformat
Ah, exzellent, exzellent
Äh, kannst du eine gute 60% hast du nur mit deutschem Leer oder empfehlen, nee habe ich nicht
Ich, ich bin jemand der mag, äh, Numplog
Okay, sehr schön
Gut, ähm, dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir mal an
Das erste was wir machen müssen ist
Wir brauchen eine Verbindung
Zu der Geschichte im Keller, also zu dem Raspberry im Keller
Ähm, das Ding läuft auf Port
Ähm, hier, 3002
Und wir können das Ganze mit Tellnet nachstellen, was wir da jetzt machen werden
Also man verbindet sich jetzt dahin
Auf eins, Port 3002, also sprich
Das ist, das ist die IP von dem Raspberry Pi im Keller
Was hast du sonst für Hobbys?
Arbeiten gehen
Und den Rest bastle ich halt daheim rum, strime was, mache ab und zu Videos
Und dann bleibt nicht mehr allzu viel Zeit übrig
So, ähm, wir sehen wir landen hier bei dem, wir landen hier bei dem
Server, also sprich
Bei der Software, die auf dem Raspberry Pi im Keller drin ist
Und da kann man jetzt sowas abfragen, wie hier, was wir hier oben gesehen haben
Get, Get-Störung
Was Schöne ist
Dass es ganz halt Remote geht
So, und das werden wir jetzt nachbauen
In.NET, also sprich das, was ich hier mit Tellnet gemacht habe
Das ist eine ganz normale TCP Socket, Socket-Verbindung
Pass of Exiles spielen, stimmt, Pass of Exiles grinde ich mir
Hardcore ein, ab grade
Ich muss sagen, meine erste Pass of Exiles, äh, Season
Ich hab ja lange nicht gespielt und jetzt seit 5 Jahren oder so mal wieder angefangen
War ziemlich erfolgreich
Okay, ich geb zu, ich spiele, äh, wahnsinnige OP-Summoner-Klasse
Aber, ich hab jetzt grade in meinem, in meinem Stash-Tab
Currency Stash-Cap hab ich 9 Exalted Orbs übrig
Äh, und einige und, und, und Chaos Orbs und Gedöns
Also ich könnte jetzt quasi noch, noch 2 neue Charakter ausstatten
Mit, mit 2 neuen Helden komplett ausstatten
Bei 9 Exalted übrigens ist doch, 9 Exalted übrigens ist doch schon, äh, schon mal nice, ja
Für, für Card Noobs wie mich, die erst mit dem Game angefangen haben
Ich hatte aber auch ziemlich viel Drop-Glück
Ich glaube ich, bei mir hat es, ich glaube 2, 2 oder 3, 3, 3 habe ich selbst gefunden
Das war halt übelst Glück
Und den Rest habe ich, äh, verkauft, äh, drops, drops verkauft
Items verkauft
Aber ich hab von dem Game vielleicht 60% kapiert bisher
Alles was sonst noch, alles was es so an Details gibt, was Crafting angeht mit, mit Fossils
Alles hab ich noch kein wenig durchblick
So, ähm, genau, also was wir jetzt brauchen ist, wir machen jetzt erstmal ne extra Klasse
Kann man, kann man, äh, kann man das gut lesen Leute, passt das?
Die Musik ist unterschiedlich laut, das geht mir auf den Keks
Es nervt mich, wenn Musik unterschiedlich laut ist
Die ist auch wieder unterschiedlich laut, die können sich wieder jetzt nicht überlegen
So
Ja, kann man lesen, ok, sind schön
Gut, dann machen wir uns jetzt erstmal ne extra Klasse, die halt für die Connection zu der Heizung zuständig ist
Die nennen wir jetzt mal, wir sind jetzt mal ein bisschen seriöser, nachdem das ganze Ding schon Heizo-Exporter heißt
Äh, nennen wir das Ding mal einfach, genauso wie das Kommando-Zeilen-Tool einfach mal wie client oder so
So, ähm, nachdem das Ding irgendwelche TCP-Verbindungen handelt, sollten wir gucken, dass das Ding auch ordentlich aufgeräumt werden kann
Hallo?
What? Ah, hier, das hab ich gesucht, ähm, das macht aktuell nix und legen wir das ganze mal an, using
So, dann brauchen wir hier die IP vom Server und den Port, also String, Host, ähm, Port
Port, wisst ihr was, hat irgendjemand ne glorreiche Idee, warum fast jeder Int für den Port nimmt?
Es leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein, wenn Port geht von 0 bis 65.535, das passt genau
Das passt, wenn man an seinen Short-16-Bit-Ding, das passt wunderbar, sind genau 65.000 äh, drinne
So, also wir merken uns mal den, wir merken uns mal den Host und den Port
Ähm, dann brauchen wir einen TCP-Client, den ich irgendwie erst noch importieren muss
Ne, ah, fuck, ne, wie schreibt man den Kram noch mal? Top, so, TCP-Client, ah ja, ah, yes
Ein Port ist doch nach Definition und Sign-Short, warum passt er da wohl genau rein? Ja, sag ich doch
Aber, äh, die meisten verwenden Interfuer, ich weiß nicht, was TCP-Client-Factory gibt, sowas ernsthaft?
Ne, hätt mich jetzt nicht gewundert, hätt mich jetzt echt nicht gewundert
Äh, was für Vorteile hat das Interface-IDs-Possible? Ähm, das hat den Vorteil, dass du Using verwenden kannst
Using, also das neue Using ist die Abkürzung von dem Using, in alten C-Sharp-Varianten musstest du sowas hier machen
Das heißt, sobald das hier aus dem Scope geht, wird automatisch das Post aufgerufen
Und nicht erst darauf gewartet, bis der Garbage-Collector mal Garbage-Collected
Alternativ könnte ich das auch weglassen und ne Close-Methode Baus basteln, die ich dann von Hand aufrufen müsste
So, ähm, jetzt muss ich dem den Host übergeben, 1, 2, 2, 1, 6, 8, 1, 5, 1 und Port war was? 3002, ne?
Genau, wunderbar
Usings, MonkaS, wer will schon keine Memory Leaks haben? Komplett unvorstellbar
Memory Leaks sind so das Salz in der Suppe eigentlich
Memory, ohne Memory Leaks ist das, ist ja auch langweilig irgendwo, ne?
So, ähm, wir machen jetzt erstmal nen Test, gucken wir erstmal, ob das überhaupt funktioniert, was ich da bastel
Wir machen jetzt mal ne
Eine Methode mit einem absolut wahnsinnig Next Level Big Brain Namen
Ähm, so, wo, wo, wo, wo connecten wir uns denn jetzt am besten?
Wo connecten wir uns denn jetzt am besten zum... zum Raspberry Pi?
Ne, wir machen das, wir machen das mal anders
Wir machen irgendwie sowas so Get Data, ich nenne Public
Ich will jetzt einfach nochmal einbauen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert
so getdata dann muss der sagen new tcp client und zwar zum host und zum port
nex cloud client hatte letztens in memory leak und dann einfach 7,6 gigabyte ram verbraucht
ja ist ja fast so fast so gut wie elektronen anwendung haben das auch dann müssen wir ausprobieren
wie viele chrome tabs man aufmachen kann für 7,6 gigabyte spoiler sind weniger als man denkt
ich weiß es nicht aber es sind wahrscheinlich wirklich weniger als man denkt man wird sich
jetzt so denken 7,6 gigabyte das reicht doch für 1000 tabs aber wahrscheinlich realistisch
betrachtet sind es wahrscheinlich 300 tabs oder so dann ist vorbei so ein kleines connect
so moment lass mal kurz lass mal kurz hier in mich in mich in mich gehen big brain also
get stream jetzt müssen wir erstmal lesen also von der idee her wenn wir uns dahin verbinden
hier gibt es ein video das wurde das von lilos tech tabs das wurde mir die ganze zeit schon
empfohlen können wir uns gleich mal angucken können erinnert mich dran erinnert mich dran
das können wir uns gleich mal angucken also wenn man sich connectet kommt dann da wie
control d als als antwort das heißt wir nehmen uns jetzt den stream und lesen einfach mal
von dem stream nachdem wir connected sind read lesen wir einfach mal 4 kilobyte in buffer
new byte byte kann man über die syntax byte 4096 so na buffer offset 0 länge da muss
uns gucken wie viel wir gelesen haben so und jetzt müssen wir das umwandeln das ist natürlich
old school das verwendet kein utf 8 encoding oder so das haben wir letztens schon ausprobiert
das ist old school old school ascii encoding so buffer wir wollen von null bis die länge
die wir gelesen haben so und jetzt wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe dann sollte
ich jetzt hier als antwort das hier bekommen also ich connecte mich jetzt zum server der
server antworten mir mit wie control d spitze klammer dings da zu und das müsste dann eigentlich
als ausgabe kommen achso habe ich das jetzt richtig gemacht schauen wir mal easy da ist
es leute guck mal hier hat funktioniert also verbindung zum raspberry pi funktioniert
das hatten wir letztens das hatten wir letztens in windows schon mal in fünf minuten zusammen
gehack sort das wissen wir dass es funktioniert aber prinzipiell ist schon mal klar die verbindung
an sich die tut die funktioniert so dann machen wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen einfacher oder
ein bisschen ordentlicher da machen wir jetzt mal wirklich so was wie ich hier gesagt habe
read string vom server also in java würde das natürlich dann heißen read string from
server with us and and ax so aber wir sind ja nicht in java wir machen das kürzer und
in java hätten wir noch irgendwie 20 factories gebraucht eigentlich nimmt sich nicht viel
eigentlich es nimmt sich wirklich nicht viel also wer wer java programmieren kann kann
auch sie scharf programmieren umgedreht aber ich habe den eindruck dass java programmierer
den hang dazu haben noch ein ticken mehr boilerplate zu schreiben als dotnet programmierer so dann
machen wir noch mal was anderes machen wir hier private was mal connect der macht nämlich
das da für mich der macht das da für mich was will der hier um weisberg ja exzellent
never sub never donate adblock uns der stonen laptop neighbors free entertainment
darf trotzdem da bleiben so also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das die big brainste lösung ist
wenn das null ist oder
ha ha ich habe noch andere idee wir können auch jetzt das hier verwenden oder kleint
connected so warte mal wie macht es jetzt am besten not ane das funktioniert nicht richtig
fragt weil das ein ein alle will bool ist das da ist da das ist dorf ok dann machen das
doch so wie ich ursprünglich hatte mir fällt jetzt gar nichts besseres ein also wenn das
wenn das null ist oder wenn das nicht connected ist oder oder operator ich weiß grad nicht
und dann egal so funktioniert auf jeden fall auch also sprich wenn er wenn es noch kein
kleinen gibt und wenn er oder wenn er nicht connected ist dann connecten wir ansonsten
aber nix kann prometors nicht direkt vom talent abfragen so get data ist das was wir publik
aufrufen deswegen kommentieren wir den kam jetzt mal aus und das erste was wir drin machen
ist uns connecten das macht er aber nur einmal und hier unten muss ich genau das gegenteil
machen wenn das da not connected ist dann muss ich sagen moment warte mal wenn übrigens
komplett die falsche benahmung hier ich verwende einmal die visual studio default settings
und einmal die writer default settings vielleicht sollte man das gerade mal umbenennen anders
war kleint weil ich auch den ganzen mist hier weg machen deswegen deswegen die not connected
ist wenn klein connected ist dann kleint das heißt da macht die verbindung jetzt automatisch
zu wenn ich hier ans ende der kannst du in this post ja einfach sagen klein disconnect
stimmt stimmt stimmt das müsste es müsste eigentlich funkt das müsste eigentlich funktionieren
oder kleint los geht so was ja das müsste das müsste funktionieren hast du dir wollte
ja ganz viel verbackt auf null prüfen das prüft er hier auf null schnausers genau das
doch eigentlich so hinhauen ok so connect haben wir jetzt den kram machen wir hier drin
also sprich den ganzen krempel den machen wir hier hier buffer länge encoding und dann
die konsole ob das sinnvoll ist was ich da bastel ob das passt erstmal ok so als muss
ich dem ding noch übergeben ok jetzt sollte das jetzt sollte im prinzip genau das gleiche
wieder rauskommen was ich vorher schon gemacht habe nur dass das vom ablaufe ein bisschen
schöner ist ja ne doch das müsste müsste passen hier unten gehen wir das mal aus
funktionieren sehr schön wie launen der muss wie launen
was wenn du in einer abfrage prüft ob null ist und gleichzeitig den wert vergleicht besteht
dann die gefahr eines crashers was verstehe ich nicht egal leuchtet mir leuchtet mir nicht
sein so jetzt kriegen wir das hier zurück das heißt was wir jetzt machen müssen ist
wir lesen das also wir lesen das weil wir kriegen ja immer dieses control gedürft warum
ist der buffer 4096 groß weil ich mir gedacht habe das passt das ist das hat keinen tieferen
sinn ich habe mir einfach gedacht 4k ist eine gute größe ich habe das hat wirklich keinen
tieferen sinn und wahrscheinlich wenn es den mehrere pakete braucht zum antworten geht
es komplett kaputt aber ich hoffe der text ist klein genug und ich komme mit kommen damit
durch was programmierst du gerade was mit dem ich meine heizung abfragen kann so also
als erstes muss ich mal kurz konzentrieren wir machen wir machen mal ein bisschen die
backausgabe dass ich später weiß was was da passiert irgendwie keine ahnung start huge
console die back so so so macht man es end so und jetzt brauchen wir als erstes müssen
wir erst mal lesen wir müssen immer einmal wenn wir uns daten abrufen wollen egal was
wir müssen immer einmal lesen damit wir dieses komische control zeug weg kriegen so ähm
übrigens dass die backausgabe ist gar nicht mal so schlecht weil später wenn ich das
ding dann bei mir auf dem raspberry laufen lasse dann sehe ich auch was er macht und
wo er abkackt so also wir müssen immer einmal den kram hier weg weg reden so dass das funktioniert
man könnte jetzt natürlich gucken der robustheit zur liebe man könnte jetzt ja gucken nach
dem motto ob nach dem ersten greet auch da drinnen v control d steht aber wir wir programmieren
ja immer perfekt also das gibt ja gar kann ja keine fehler geben im endeffekt deswegen
lassen wir das jetzt einfach so dann brauchen wir noch so was hier das nennen wir jetzt
mal write string wie auch sonst so und das ist was er zum server schickt morgen ist
die heizung abgebrannt ja und das ist das was er zum server schickt das dürfte noch
mal eine ganze ecke ähm simpler aussehen nämlich einfach kleines stream ähm stream
rups öh kann ich schreiben stream write und da schreiben jetzt schreiben jetzt das kommando
rein also alter was macht der da da schreiben jetzt das kommando rein was so nicht geht
sondern ich erstmal in bytes umwandeln muss ok also encoding ask get bytes vom vom s so
dann schreiben wir das hier rein jetzt müssen wir jetzt schreiben wir die bytes in den stream
zwar von anfang an also wenn morgen die heizung explodiert ist leute wisst ihr wisst ihr warum
äh falls ich irgendwie was über sehe muss das noch mal schreiben ich muss mich gerade
kurz mal konzentrieren dass mir da was einfällt das wird das wird nicht viel viel mehr hier
brauchen so wir schreiben jetzt ein kommando rein um zu gucken ob das ganze funktioniert
brauchen wir jetzt mal einen kommando was ich also write string und da nehmen wir jetzt
mal leute was wollen wir denn abfragen was wollen wir mal abfragen was haltet ihr von
get temp wie wie ist das ist so die wichtigste information jetzt erstmal also warm wasser
temperatur wie sie aktuell ist huge benahmung von denen ich weiß das ist nicht auf meine
mist gewachsen dass das zeug so heißt also wir fragen wir fragen jetzt mal hier ab das
war mal anders das war mal anders ich weiß wie das man das ist hier das ist das was
davor rauskommt aber ein bisschen die backbö ein bisschen die backausgabe damit ich auch
sehe dass der kram funktioniert da sollte dann immer wie control d rauskommen danach
mal ein command command command ist in dem fall get temp plus ein new line das new line
mache ich absichtlich ich mache das absichtlich so hin das ergibt zwar keinen sinn ich könnte
es ja ohne probleme da hinschreiben weil hier kommt er dann später das eigentliche dynamische
kommando hin also das ist ja nicht immer get temp ist das soll ja unterschiedliche kommandos
geben so dann dann geben wir das noch mal aus etwas mal command so dann schicken wir
das command ab also sprich wir schreiben jetzt get temp ist unten ein new line schicken
wir jetzt an den server ein bob google plus ist auch schon längst weg das ist aber nicht
das ist ziemlich low-prane jetzt noch bob zu schreiben so und jetzt müssen wir die antwort
lesen also von der idee her macht er jetzt ja folgendes der verbindet sich zum server
liest einmal wie control d weg aus dem also liest das einmal aus dem stream raus dass
es quasi danach nicht rum saut so dann sage ich get get temp wie wie ist hast du erfahrung
mit funktionaler programmierung nur ganz so ganz am rande also könnte jetzt kein f sharp
oder haskell programm zusammen wussten neonymus das ist das ist ziemlich leise copypasta kennt
könnt ihr die pyramide könnt ihr die pyramiden copypasta nicht die pyramiden die die die
dosen stapel copypasta er könnte die könnte die wer schafft wer schafft sie dosen wer
schafft sie dosen auf seinem auf seinem kopf zu balancieren wer schafft das wer schafft
die die die twitch wer schafft die kanz vor sich zu balancieren chat jetzt sehe ich einfach
spamm auch mal zeigen dass man was kann monka tost werbung echt was war da noch gar keine
monka tost werbung die sehen halt oft oft auf twitch ist das halt so mittlerweile only
choice und kann es nicht fast fast knapp vorbei schon mal nicht schlecht was hast du eigentlich
gelernt ich habe mal irgendwann fachinformatiker systemintegration gelernt ewig her der chat
tut sich schwer der chat tut sich echt schwer mit dem stapeln der einzige das bisher richtig
gut geschafft hat ist xd xd xd xd xdd xdd xe xd xdd es sonst hat so keiner hingekriegt
ich sehe der chat freut sich jetzt hat jetzt celle beschäftigt so jetzt macht er get temples
Wie ist und dann kriegt er als antwort 47 grad 747 was das schon für eine unformatierte krabb antwort
47,5
500 grad Celsius komplett random einfach nur wird das formatiert hat er
Slay dat teddy abonniert wird spiel nice dankeschön
Nö, ihr kriegt es nicht hin
Werden das nicht fast schon eher dass es ein deutsch-anwältungsentwicklung gerade ja
So also ich muss kurz kurz konzentrieren also ich schreibe jetzt ich schicke jetzt an den server er soll get temp
mir mir zurück zurückschicken
Und dementsprechend will ich jetzt als will ich jetzt eine antwort haben nämlich noch mal
das nächste was ans antwort kriege müsste dann
Müssten dann die daten sein die ich haben will
Hau ma ma das funktioniert
So weit so gut schau aufs funktionieren
Leute data 47,5 grad Celsius funktioniert funktioniert
huge
Crash in 3 2 1 gibt es da keine communication lip dazu nein
Gibt es nicht es gibt den offiziellen client
Aber den offiziellen client passen wir auf
Offiziellen client den will man sich nicht angucken
Weil
Das sind
Da der geht sogar der geht sogar da ist da weil das halt
sehr rohr der offizielle klein der
Vor allem die die haben wir da die best benannte variablen namen überhaupt ja also wir haben hier ein
rptr
Und der c also
rptr plus plus wird c zugewiesen dann haben wir mit temp zwischendurch dann haben wir noch ein
p pointer
Also nur vom feinsten nur vom feinsten
Da weiß man so weiß man sofort da weiß man gleich was passiert
Ja also ich meine wer wüsste nicht
wenn hier quasi
rptr plus plus ist c also da ist doch kammer ist doch ganz klar ganz klar was da sache ist
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt anders warum machen wir das jetzt anders nach ohne uns das anzugucken
Denn joshina developer der knäbär zieht alle register was was copypasta heute angeht oder
Aber
Was ist das für eine heizung der ausgelesen wird eine diesmal also mein weinkeller bei der wei
Eine wiesmann veto dens 2 2 2
Endlich immer ein bisschen copypasta action im chat das hat das war mir schon zu wenig die letzten streams
Ok das hier funktioniert alles sehr gut das heißt jetzt kann ich
Jetzt wollen wir mal sowas also was wollen wir auslesen wir wollen
Die get temp wie wie ist auslesen das heißt wir machen das jetzt mal ganz ordentlich
Was sagen wir wir machen jetzt mal einen enum
Mit allem was wir an kommandos drinne haben das nennen wir mal commands
Da haben wir zum beispiel get temp wie wie ist und da haben wir zum beispiel get brenner staats haben wir da noch
dann haben wir sowas wie
Get temp wie wie es soll aber das reicht erst mal zum ausprobieren
Wiesmann kann per telnet angesprochen werden naja so halb
Wiesmann selber hat kein offizielles interface
Das einzige was die haben ist die haben der anschluss vorne an der heizung und man so einen opto
koppel also opto link kabel anschließen kann also dass es kommt
Quasi wenn man dann raspberry pi dran anschließt kommt dann serielle serielles interface bei bei raus als device
Als device und vorne sind da infrarot leds dran und die kommunizieren mit irgendeinem special
Wiesmann wie auch immer geartetem ding mit der heizung
So und es haben paar findige leute allerdings ein open source projekt gestartet nämlich wie control
Und das haben die die haben quasi dieses wiesmann
Wiesmann opto dings protokoll reverse
Ingeniert oder oder anhand von der wiesmann docks irgendwie nachgebaut
Und wenn man auf dem raspberry pi drauf ist und sich wie control die kompiliert hat dann kann man hier abfragen machen
So das schöne ist das wie control die selber erlaubt dass man über das netzwerk abfragt
Und das mache ich hier unten kann von meinem rechner was ich jetzt mache ist ich verbinde mich mit meinem programm
Zu dem zum wie control d und mache abfragen damit ich den kram später in grafana
exportieren kann beziehungsweise in prometors exportieren kann dass es ins grafana reinkommt und dann habe ich quasi einen schönen graf über
die
Jetzt wird jetzt übertreibt man nicht im chat
Deswegen sieht man dann nachher im chat im chat im craft
Ah
Was meine temperatur von der heizung so treibt
Sollte ich jetzt auch mal ein meme textdokument aufmachen ich habe ein extra textdokument mit irgendwie 500 zeilen mit twitch memes und copypastas
Also ich habe für jeden für jeden fall ist da was drinnen
So das heißt wir sagen jetzt mal was fragen wir jetzt mal ab hier get temp bw ist gut
Das heißt das wollen wir publik haben
Temp temperatur machen wir mal ein double das ist ja was mit mit nachkommastellen
Übrigens leute wir haben ein extra discord channel für die besten twitch copypasta
Und real only real luller kann nee das ist dumm
Die pyramide die als ich die stack kenne sind besser
Das haben nur die neuen wie man andere unsere hat kein opto link. Oh das ist natürlich doof
Da gibt es aber bestimmt andere varianten was man machen kann
Über 30.000 abgesehen
Da gibt es aber bestimmt andere varianten was man machen kann übertreiben zwar nicht so sehr mit dem großen ascii bildern
Dann sehe ich nämlich den chat nicht also wer jetzt noch große ascii bilder rumspermte wird timeoutet
Alles andere ist gut aber die großen ascii bilder sehe ich den chat nicht mehr richtig
Ich
Eine heizung hat sogar laden ja siehst du
Die
Warum machst du das ganze stream retry mit encoding selber ja weil
Genau
Ich weiß nicht könnte ich könnte ich auch im stream wieder fahrt ach so nee könnte ich nicht
Könnte ich nicht
Weil ich glaube stream reader hängt oder wenn ich dem nicht sagen kann bis wohin er reden soll
Mit der
Warum kommt am ende auch noch einmal kommt am ende ne reckless
Weil weil ich hier fail weil weil ich hier misprogrammiere
Ich muss data return und nicht noch mal noch mal ich rede ja quasi dass dass doppelte
Ich hab, ich hab ein Mist gemacht. Der Chat, der Chat lenkt mich ab.
Okay, get data. So, das war mal private. Der kriegt einen Command.
So, und das Command kommt dann an der Stelle hin. Nämlich CMD.
Ach so. Ah, äh, äh, äh. Nee, das kann ich nicht so nennen.
Schreib ich's halt aus. Perfekt. String, Command. Wunderbar.
So, ähm, so. Also, jetzt lesen wir mal die Temperatur aus. Dem Ding geben wir jetzt mal den ordentlichen Namen.
Diesmal hat das Ding ja genannt getVVist. Und wir nennen das Ganze jetzt mal so, dass man ein bisschen was damit anfangen kann.
Current water temp. Oder? Das klingt auch schon mal ganz sinnvoll. Da kann man sich wenigstens vorstellen, was es ist.
Ja, stimmt. Choose my name. Könnte ich echt machen.
So. Current water temp. Ähm, so. Das müssen wir jetzt abfragen. Und zwar sagen wir jetzt this get data.
Das hab ich mir vor Visual Studio angewöhnt. Und zwar füttern wir jetzt an diesen E-Namen rein.
Und dann sagen wir einfach. Nee. Ach, Quatsch. Ich muss das erst mal parsen. Das ist ein Blödsinn. Was mach ich denn hier?
Ähm, hier. Result. So, ähm.
Ähm. Ich muss das parsen. Also double. Pars. Result. So. Oh, nee. Das funktioniert so nicht.
Aber ich lass es einmal crashen. Das funktioniert so nicht. Aber mal probieren. Ja.
Also es kann nicht funktionieren. Aber, äh, weil die Ausgabe nicht passt. Aber ich will mal gucken, ob es überhaupt bis zum Crash kommt.
Oh. Oh. MonkaS. Macht der denn da jetzt? Ich will das nicht de-kompiliert haben. Nein.
Ich will das nicht de-kompiliert haben. Ich will einfach sehen, wo es die Exception gibt.
What the fuck? I thought. Ich will einfach sehen, wo es die Exception gibt, dass das zu viel verlangt.
Ah, yes. Input String was not in correct Format. Correct. Mein Input String ist im komplett falschen Format.
Äh, weil mein Input String ist das da. Und ich will die Zahl da rauskriegen.
Das heißt, ich will, keine Ahnung, Split. Oder wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Split. Split am Leerzeichen. Und dann nehmen wir das erste.
Probieren wir es mal so.
Ah, yes. Funktioniert. 47,5999. Passt. Kommt das Richtige zurück.
Äh, eine Sache sollten wir jetzt noch machen. Und deswegen machen wir das vielleicht mal eher nicht in-line.
Eine Sache sollten wir noch machen, nämlich. Das Problem ist jetzt.
Die Zahl, also die Heizung. Die Heizung sagt ja, aktuelle Wassertemperatur.
Übrigens, das schreibe ich da nicht hin. Das ist eins zu eins das, was quasi von der Heizung zurückkommt.
47,5999. 8 Grad Celsius. Das kommt da eins zu eins so zurück.
Eins zu eins so zurück. Da ist doch gar kein Double notwendig. Da reicht ein Float. Richtig.
So. Ähm, eine Sache, die wir noch, die wir noch machen sollten, ist.
Wir müssen dem Ding sagen. Ähm.
Dann nehmen wir halt Float. Als hätten wir hier irgendwelche, als hätten wir hier irgendwelche Memoryprobleme, ey.
So.
Dann machen wir jetzt das, wenn es Float. Wenn, wenn, wenn wir jetzt, wenn ihr, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie, was sind das, 4 Bytes oder so sparen wollt, dann, das ist natürlich, äh, unglaublich wichtig, dass wir 4 Bytes jetzt sparen. Dann machen wir das so.
So. Also eine Sache, die wir noch unbedingt machen müssen, ist.
Ähm, hab ich vergessen, wo ich bin. Bin, irgendwo muss ich hin.
Ja. Ähm, wir müssen hier noch angeben, was der für, oh, fuck, nicht da, sondern, äh, da, das muss ich jetzt mal da raus machen, das ist wirklich eklig.
Eklig. Ähm, wir müssen hier angeben, was der für einen, was der bei den Zahlen für einen, für einen Länder, äh, wie nennt man das?
Culture Standard verwendet, weil es ist so, wenn der Englisch verwendet, ist okay, also sprich im Englischen ist das Punkt, ist der Punkt quasi das Komma, bei uns ist es aber das Komma der Punkt.
Das heißt, ich muss dem jetzt irgendwie sagen, ähm, Culture Info, Culture Info, keine Ahnung, Culture Info, mach, mach, äh, ach, keine Ahnung, EN oder so.
Mach einfach Replace, ne, Replace bringt, bringt es ja auch nicht, weil, ähm, wenn ich, wenn ich, ähm, sagen wir mal, ich replace, Punkt durch Komma, dann ist es genau andersrum falsch.
Jetzt funktioniert es nicht, wenn ich in Deutschland bin, und wenn ich das andersrum replace, funktioniert es nicht richtig, wenn ich in, in USA bin, also richtig Kokona Style.
Also ich müsste jetzt hier irgendwie so Culture oder so, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das so funktioniert hat.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das so funktioniert hat. Und jetzt, wenn jetzt quasi sagt hier, wir sind in EN, US oder so, und jetzt haben wir hardcoded, dass ein Punkt Brennzeichen ist, das jetzt funktioniert das auch immer, geht's.
Genau, wenn die Heizung über 1000 Grad hat, dann, dann ist auf einmal ein Dezimal Trennpunkt und so dabei.
Dann ist allerdings Monka Explosion angesagt. So, so ist es doch schön, so gefällt mir das. So, jetzt kriegen wir das zurück, eine Sache müssen wir noch machen, und zwar, was passiert denn?
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Was gibt es denn als Antwort, wenn ich hier Mist reinschreibe? Das können wir nämlich mal ausprobieren.
Also wenn ich hier in das Command irgendeinen Crap reinschreibe, den es nicht gibt, was passiert denn dann?
Dann kommt als Antwort Error, Command Unknown. Okay, das können wir relativ einfach abfackeln, indem wir sagen, wenn die Antwort, weil wir wollen ja dann nicht, dass der weiter passt, sondern da soll eine Fehlermeldung werfen, Antwort ist Crap.
Das heißt, wir gucken jetzt hier, if data start mit Error, dann Exception raushauen mit dem kompletten Inhalt.
So, das heißt, wenn wir jetzt Fehler lesen, sollte ich eine Exception kriegen, wo drinnen steht, Command Unknown. Genau, da kann man nämlich auch was mit anfangen.
Und er kann ja in der, er kann ja gar nicht weitermachen an der Stelle. Ich meine, da kommt nichts zurück. Er kann ja, er kann ja schlecht irgendeine Zahl zurückliefern, was die aktuelle Wassertemperatur ist, wenn die Abfrage nicht funktioniert hat.
So, dann lassen wir das jetzt mal hier so drinnen. So, und das war es im Großen und Ganzen schon. Jetzt können wir die ganzen einzelnen Kommandos einbauen und es funktioniert.
Dann bauen wir noch ein zweites Kommando ein. Also was wir jetzt hier haben ist, also aktuell das einzige, was wir haben jetzt hier, aktuelle Wassertemperatur. Dann bauen wir jetzt noch ein, nennen wir das mal Target Wassertemperatur.
Also sprich, das, wie viel es sein soll. Und das ist in dem Fall hier GetTempBWSoll. Weil, geile Benamung. Und dann passt das. Das müssten 55 Grad sein. Können wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Macht doch eine Methode, die immer die Temps passen kann. Könnte ich auch machen.
Weiß jemand, wie man in C-Sharp ordentlich, also ordentliche, also hier zum Beispiel an der Stelle. In dem Kommando, in dem Antwort sind Control-Character drinnen.
Hat irgendjemand eine gute Idee, wie ich eine Debug-Ausgabe machen kann auf die Konsole. So was wie P in Ruby. Was mir, fällt mir nämlich gerade nichts ein. Was mir den String quasi ausgibt mit allen Escape-Sequenzen drinnen. Und sie nicht auf die Kommandozeile schreibt.
Ich hätte einen ziemlich verschwenderischen Ansatz. Ich könnte das nämlich einfach nach Jason konvertieren. Und dann ausgeben. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht die schönste Variante.
Oh, Jason Convert, ist es ja auch. Ich mein, das Jason Ding brauchen wir eh nachher noch. Kannst du auch Power, ich kann alles auslesen aus der Heizung. Alles, alles was die Heizung auslesbar hat.
Ich könnte Regex replacen oder, ich weiß aber nicht, was ich alles replacen muss. Also ich mein, die einfachste Variante, die mir jetzt so einfällt ist tatsächlich das hier. Aber das ist auch keine, das ist definitiv keine schöne Variante.
Too literal? Nee, das kann nicht sein Florian. Das gibt es nicht. Das kann nicht sein. Oh, Stack Overflow, Stack Overflow Leute. Huge. Der Twitch Chat denkt mit.
Can I Convert a C Sharp String Value to an S-Cablet? What? Oh, der Tommy schreibt da was. Geht das? Was macht das? Prozent C? Was macht Prozent C?
Nee. So? So? Nee. Na? Nee.
Was ist das für ein abgedrehtes Ding? Ich hab, ich hab legit. Ich hab legit keinen Plan, was das Ding hier macht.
Generate Code from Expression. Oh, das ist glaub ich keine allzu gute Idee. Hast du auch ein, ich hab nur ein Stonks Meme. Das ist keine so gute Idee. Der Input könnte ja alles sein.
Und der macht da irgendwie C Sharp Code. Es scheint komplizierter zu sein als ich mir das vorstelle.
Weil ohne Data am Anfang. Meinst du einfach nur so? Nee, die Syntax stimmt auch so gar nicht. Die Rideline Syntax ist anders. Die Rideline Syntax ist das hier.
So geht das nicht. Aber da muss es doch irgendwas, irgendwas schöneres geben als das. Kann doch nicht sein, dass ich Jason serialize muss dafür.
C Sharp Print String with Escape Characters. Also das hatten wir grad schon. Also im Prinzip Regex Escape? Nee, da macht aber kein U-Line.
Nee, nee, nee. Add Test sorgt ja dafür, dass der gar nichts eskept. Ja.
Ja, nee, das weiß ich auch, wie ich es ausgebe. Wisst ihr was, wir halten uns jetzt gar nicht so lange drauf aus. Wir ruhen uns da jetzt gar nicht.
Ich machs jetzt auf meine Noob Variante. Ich konvertiere das Ding einfach zu Jason und gut ist. Wenn uns was besseres einfällt, können wir das immer noch ersetzen.
Ich gebe zu, es ist echt keine schöne Variante, das nach Jason zu konvertieren. Nur, dass ich quasi den Kram ausgegeben kriege, aber es funktioniert.
Guckt her. Jason, Dings, hab ich hier die Escape Characters. Alles, alles gut.
Wenn jemand anderes noch Big Brain genug ist, dass ihr euch was besseres einfällt, her damit. Dann bau ich das ein, aber mir fällt grad nichts anderes ein.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht stringen, hex um, und dann?
Dann hab ich, ich will den Text ja behalten. Ich will ja sehen, was da drin steht.
Was ist an Jason so schlecht? Nix, aber es ist halt ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge quasi nur, damit ich die Konsolenausgabe richtig habe, erst das Ganze in Jason zu konvertieren.
So, gut, es funktioniert. Wir haben Target Wassertemperatur, sonst was Wassertemperatur. Guckt hier, 55 Grad, 47,6 Grad.
Oh Leute, wir hätten doch Double nehmen sollen. Wir haben nicht genug Precision. Monka Precision, Alter. Wir haben, wir haben nicht genug hier. Es reicht nicht.
Wir haben einen Fehler der Temperatur um 0,0000002 Grad. Indiskutabel, das geht nicht.
Hört euch mal vor, was 0,0000002 Grad alles so ausmachen können. Also doch Double verwenden. Oder damit leben, als wenn die Heizung so genau wäre.
Big Int, genau. Unlimited Precision. Wir machen erstmal einen kompletten Ramm voll.
Platzier einen Backslash. Nee, das funktioniert nicht. Ich will den Backslash, ich will ja, dass der wirklich das verschickt. Ich will bloß hier nicht auf die Konsole printen. Wenn ich das so mache, dann funktioniert zwar die Ausgabe, aber das eigentliche Kommando funktioniert nicht mehr.
Militärgrader Heizung. So, okay, funktioniert alles Leute. Alles wunderbar. Jetzt können wir Prometheus einbauen. GitHub Prometheus.net. Das habe ich mir vorhin schonmal angeguckt, deswegen weiß ich, dass es das gibt.
Und das Beispiel sah ziemlich simpel aus. Man macht einfach einen Server auf und freut sich seines Lebens. Wir brauchen einen Googleplex für ausreichende Präzision.
Es ist schon enorm wichtig, dass es an der sechsten Nachkommastelle einen Fehler hat. Regex Replays von N zu N. Das könnte ich machen, ja. Aber besser gefallen tut mir das trotzdem nicht. Zumal ich ja hier spätestens dort gar nicht genau weiß, wie die Ausgabe ist, die zurückkommt.
Trim. Nee, nee, nee. Ich will den nicht weghaben. Ich will das Newline nicht weghaben. Ich will in der Ausgabe sehen, dass da ein Newline ist. Und ich will in der Ausgabe von der Response sehen, dass da Control-Character drin sind, wenn sie drin sind.
Ohne sie zu löschen, will sie einfach sehen und nicht auf der Kommandozeile quasi einen Tab haben. Ich will da Backslash-T sehen. Also das ist das Simpelste, was mir einfällt. Da kann sie nach Jason konfrontieren.
Also, weiter geht's. Bau mal Prometheus ein, das ist eigentlich was wir machen wollten. So, das machen wir mal weg. Matrix-Server. Find. Prometheus-Net. Install. Yes, excellent.
Ja, dass das in C geht, mag sein, aber das bringt mir jetzt nichts. Oder soll ich dafür extra noch mal einen unsafe-code mit Interop einbauen dafür? Nee, ich glaube, das ist keine so gute Idee.
Moonbeard Desmond, das könnte eventuell... Nee, das funktioniert auch nicht. Das macht doppelte Backslashes an Stellen, die gar keine Escape-Zeichen sind.
Ich bleib bei meinem Jason-Zeug, sofern es jetzt nichts Kürzeres, Eleganteres einfällt. Sleep. Sekunde kann ich sleepen, okay, da kann ich mit leben.
So, bla, bla, bla. Start. Localhost. Port 1234. Localhost bringt mir nichts, ich muss überall dran lauschen. Port 1234 ist okay.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt starte, dann sollte ich... Oh, oh je. Der ist gerade kaputt gegangen. Was hat der für Schmerzen gehabt?
Oh. Gut. Haben die keine.NET-Fession oder was?
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, ob es trotzdem geht. Funktioniert trotzdem. So, wenn ich jetzt auf Localhost, Port 1234 gehe... Ach ne, 100 Found. Matrix.
Da hab ich meine Prometheus-Metriken. Das sind nur Warnings, aber ich mag Warnings trotzdem nicht. So, was hab ich denn für eine IP? Die da? Weil die muss ich jetzt in meiner Prometheus-Config hinterlegen.
Und dann kann ich Sachen abrufen. Jetzt muss ich natürlich nur noch sicherstellen, dass der auch die Werte von meiner Heizung exportiert. Was er aktuell noch nicht macht. Dann muss ich mal schauen, wie das funktioniert. Hier. So exportiert man wohl Sachen.
Copy-Paste mir das jetzt einfach mal. Public Static Read Account... Counter? Oh, Counter? Nee. Was haben wir denn sonst noch so? Counters. Only increase in value. Nee, das ist für Temperatur ziemlich doof. Temperatur kann hoch und runter gehen.
Gauges. Wie spricht man das aus? Gaihuts? Was?
Gauges. Gauges. Gauges.
Da hab ich auch grad dran gedacht, Alter. Gauges. Gauges? Das hört sich ein bisschen kappa breit an.
Gaihuts. Gaihuts. Gaihuts. Gaihuts. Okay, also Gauges. Any numeric value. Das find ich gut. Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Wie nennen wir das? Jobs in queue ist schonmal falsch. Jobs in queue soll das Ganze nicht heißen, sondern das Ding heißt jetzt...
Hallo, kann ich mal ordentlich kopieren. Current temp. Wie nenne ich denn das jetzt? Vito dense current temp. So ist das, wie das Ganze dann im Grafana auch später heißt.
So ein Hilfetext, dass ich später irgendwann mal noch weiß, was es ist. Current water temperature. So, das exportieren wir auch noch und dann machen wir noch target temp.
Das lassen wir jetzt exportieren und dann machen wir es ins Prometheus rein und gucken, ob es funktioniert. Und dann machen wir einen schönen Graf mit meiner water temperature.
Achso, ich schreibe da gar nichts rein. Keck weh. Ich schreibe da gar nichts rein. Muss erst noch mal einen neuen thread aufmachen, der hier Zeug abfragt.
Task. Machen wir. Task run. Zack. Endlosschleife. So muss das sein.
So muss das sein. Cool. Hab ich denn nicht beides schon drin? Target water temp.
Also sagen wir jetzt hier, wie habe ich das Ding an Current temp value gleich das und Target temp value ist.
So.
Task Factory. Du meinst, wir können einmal noch mal. Was hat er denn für Schmerzen eigentlich?
Was? Karnevalsumzug Auto fährt in Menge in Hessen. Was? Es ist es ist vom Karnevalsumzug ein Umzug Auto über Leute drüber gefahren oder was?
Sleep. Ja, auf jeden Fall Sleep. Rosenmontagszug. Was?
Zeig mal her. Oh, ich kann die Seite nicht. Ich kann die Seite nicht aufmachen. Walddeckische Landeszeigungen. Das ist das Weltplatz schlechthin anscheinend.
Firefox stoppt Social Network from tracking. Ja, sehr gut. Exzellent. Autofahrer rast absichtlich in Menschberg 347 davon schwer. Oh, Autsch. Und wo? Das ist gar nicht so weit weg hier. Das ist wieder in Hessen.
Ich glaube irgendwie. Also unsere hochrangigen Politiker kommen langsam nicht mehr raus aus der ganzen Geschichte. Die müssen ja wirklich fast täglich oder oder zumindest wöchentlich.
1 2 Beileids Tweets absetzen. Die haben wahrscheinlich einen Bot laufen. Beileids Bekundung Spots.
Unklar. Okay, mal gucken, was da alles rauskommt. Ups.
Ja, muss man abwarten, was da rauskommt. Ja, gut. Twitter. Twitter ist normal. Ich kann es verstehen. Ich kann es verstehen, dass es so viele Leute interessiert, wo die Täter herkommen. Das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Allerdings, was ich halt bei den ganzen Sachen immer echt fragwürdig finde, ist, wenn quasi alle Seiten nur darauf warten, dass irgendwas rauskommt, um sich dann die Rübe einschlagen zu können.
Und die beste Begründung ist ja dann immer, so nach dem Motto, ja, die anderen sind auch so schlimm. Ganz ehrlich, wenn mich jemand überfährt, also für mich persönlich ist das eigentlich scheißegal, ob mich jetzt am Hauptbahnhof ein zugewanderter Schweizer Ausländer,
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, vor einem Zug stößt, ich wäre überfahren, ob mich irgendwie ein total gestörter rechtsextremistischer Typ erschießt, also für mich unterm Strich ist das eigentlich, wenn es mich getroffen hat, ist da so wenig Unterschied dazwischen.
Ja, aber das ist echt ein Thema, da muss ich jetzt wieder weiter ausholen, wenn ich da meinen Senf dazu geben will.
Eine Sache finde ich aber wirklich schade, bei den ganzen Sachen wieder mit umgegangen wird, nämlich, dass es hauptsächlich darum geht, dass wieder versucht wird, verschiedene Gruppierungen gegeneinander auszuspielen.
Es geht doch eigentlich viel mehr um die Frage, was kann man allgemein tun gegen Terrorangriffe, wir können das ja mal so zusammenfassen, ist es ja, es ist doch im Prinzip, die wichtige Frage ist doch, was kann man gegen Terrorangriffe machen, ob das jetzt islamistische Terroristen sind,
ob das Leute in Norwegen da bereivig sind, was kann man allgemein dagegen machen und im Prinzip hört man ja immer nur irgendwelche Bekundungen, so nach dem Motto, wir müssen hier die Polizei stellen, wir müssen das und das hier machen, ohne dass im Endeffekt großartig was passiert.
Und ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal, gegen gut organisierte Einzeltäter kann man nichts machen, außer totale Überwachung und da ist halt die Frage, ob man das will.
Was willst du gegen gut organisierte Einzeltäter machen, die quasi bereit sind, Leute umzubringen und es sie überhaupt nicht interessiert, ob sie die Sache überleben, was willst du da großartig dagegen machen?
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, VPN, da läuft es ja aktuell drauf raus, ja, also solche Anschläge werden auch ganz gerne dazu instrumentalisiert zu sagen, hey Leute, wir brauchen viel mehr Überwachung, wir brauchen hier das und das und sonst was und hier stärkere Kontrollen und hier mehr Vorratsdatenspeicherung und sonst was.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man Leute quasi frei leben lässt und trotzdem solche Anschläge hundertprozentig verhindern kann, das geht beides in Kombination gar nicht.
In Hanau waren das, so wie ich das mitgekriegt habe, nur einer, wobei man sich da auch nicht so ganz sicher war. Was ich halt schade finde, ist, dass da wirklich auch auf Kosten der Opfer und der Hinterbliebenen wieder verschiedene Gruppierungen das gegeneinander, gegeneinander ausspielen müssen.
Ich meine, man sieht das jetzt schon, dass die Gesellschaft relativ gespalten ist, man muss sich nur mal das Ganze in Thüringen angucken. Die, die im Endeffekt in Thüringen dazu gewinnen, sind die auf der linken Seite und die auf der rechten Seite.
Der Mitte wird das immer dünner und das ist zunehmend schon die letzten Jahre so. Also du bist entweder, heutzutage bist du entweder für irgendwas oder gegen irgendwas.
Zu dem, zu dem Standpunkt so nach dem Motto, war jetzt zwar vielleicht nicht meine, wäre nicht meine Wahl gewesen, aber ich kann damit leben oder umgedreht, ich fand's eigentlich nicht gut, aber hat mich doch überzeugt, gibt's immer weniger.
Also es gibt, es gibt, du bist entweder dafür oder dagegen. So ganz so in der Mitte, so gibt es, gibt's wenig noch, ja.
Oder zumindest welche, die sich, sagen wir mal so weniger, weniger so nach dem Motto, das so komplett überzeugt sind, so das ist das einzig wahre und die andere Seite auch, das ist das einzig wahre.
Ja, das, Mitte, Mitte ist das falsche Wort, Mitte ist das falsche Wort, man muss einfach sehen, wie die Welt, dass die Welt nicht schwarz und weiß ist, ich glaube das trifft's eigentlich am besten.
Man muss, man muss einfach sehen, dass die Welt nicht schwarz und weiß ist, dass die Welt meistens irgendwie, die Wahrheit liegt meistens irgendwo dazwischen.
Und es hat keinen Sinn, wenn man nur alles Schwarze sieht oder nur alles Weiße sieht. Wisst ihr, wie ich das mein? Das bringt nichts.
Zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt, in Frankfurt haben sie vor ein paar Monaten, haben sie eine Mutter und das Kind hat einen Ausländer aus der Schweiz, der kam aus der Schweiz, weiß nicht, was er für eine Nationalität war, hab ich nicht mehr im Kopf.
Aber es war kein Schweizer, es war, ich sag jetzt mal jemand aus Afrika, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, hat jemand eine Mutter und das Kind vor den Zug geschmissen und das Kind wurde überfahren.
So, da war Twitter außer sich und hat sich drüber aufgeregt, so nach dem Motto, dass die Ausländer in Deutschland das größte Problem wären.
Jetzt ist das in Hanau passiert, da kommen alle anderen wieder an, ja, Nazis sind das Problem.
Ich frag mich halt immer, wie gesagt, die Welt ist nicht schwarz und weiß, könnte es nicht vielleicht sein, dass es nicht das Problem gibt, bzw. nicht ein Problem und wenn man das behebt, ist alles gut?
Könnte es nicht viel wahrscheinlicher sogar sein, dass es einfach schlicht und ergreifend mehrere Probleme gibt?
Das eine schließt das andere doch nicht aus, das ist ja das blöde an Problemen, Probleme aldieren sich ja eigentlich in der Regel, also Probleme sind nicht exklusiv, das weiß jeder von sich.
Also wer ein Problem hat und dann ein anderes Problem bekommt, der hat nicht auf einmal das erste Problem nicht mehr und umgedreht, der hat dann eher zwei Probleme, die wahrscheinlich zusammen größer sind als eins für sich betrachtet.
Deswegen finde ich es immer blöd, dass dann, wie gesagt, es läuft aktuell darauf raus, dass verschiedene Gruppierungen sich, also die Leute gegeneinander ausspielen wollen.
Was die Spaltung der Leute natürlich auch nicht besser macht, das ist ja nicht nur bei diesen viel diskutierten Themen, sprich Migrationspolitik, Terroristen, Nazis und sonst was so ist,
sondern dass es bei ganz alltäglichen Sachen schon anfängt.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, dass Leute, die wenig verdienen, Rentner, die wenig verdienen, Hartz-IV-Empfänger und Asylbewerber und was nicht alles, sprich Leute, die allesamt eigentlich so gut wie keine Kohle bekommen,
dass die Leute schon gegeneinander ausgespielt werden, dass die aufeinander stinkig sind, dass der andere fünf Euro mehr kriegt.
Da fängt das Ganze ja schon an.
Hier ist ein Serial Forever Key, MonkaS.
Man kann sich hier einfach Serial Keys kopieren.
ETF. No Warritz hier bei mir im Channel. Toss. Richtig, richtig Toss.
Also ich denke, es gibt mehrere Probleme. Und umso mehr Probleme man hat, umso größer wird das Ganze eigentlich nur.
Und unterm Strich ist, dass in den seltensten Fällen ist was klar weiß und klar schwarz auf der Welt. Es liegt meistens irgendwo dazwischen.
So, aber jetzt genug dazu.
Ich meine, man hat es doch gesehen, das muss ich jetzt nochmal loswerden, man hat es doch gesehen, dass man gegen gut organisierte Einzeltäter relativ wenig machen kann, wenn die bereit sind, im Zweifelsfall auch drauf zu gehen bei solchen Aktionen.
Es ist doch vor ein paar Jahren einer in den Weihnachtsmarkt reingefahren und darauf hin hat man irgendwelche Boller aufgestellt, dass das nicht mehr passieren kann.
Und hat was gebracht? Nee. Entweder werden andere Wege gefunden oder es werden sich Veranstaltungen rausgesucht, wo das nicht so ist.
Im Prinzip stellt sich ja nur die Frage, willst du so weit wie möglich dich frei entfalten können oder willst du, dass alles hundertprozentig überwacht wird?
Das ist das einzige, was du machen kannst, um theoretisch vorzubeugen gegen alle Eventualitäten. Und ich glaube, das will keiner.
Deswegen wüsste ich nicht, was man dann großartig gegen machen soll. Was man natürlich dagegen machen kann, ist, man muss sich die Ursachen angucken.
Also sprich, wie gesagt, es gibt ja nicht ein Problem, was man angehen muss. Man muss sich die Ursachen angucken und erstmal muss man zu Einsicht gelangen, es gibt mehrere Probleme, die sowas auslösen, egal aus welcher Richtung.
Und da muss man sich die Ursachen angucken, was bringt die Leute denn dazu?
Es ist glaube ich ein bisschen einfach zu sagen, ok, der eine war einfach nur gestört oder so nach dem Motto, ja, Ausländer sind halt gewaltbereiter, statistisch gesehen, mag das stimmen.
Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass das auf irgendeine spezielle Tat jetzt zutrifft. Das muss man sich schon genau angucken, was da passiert ist.
Und wenn man sich anguckt, warum Leute so handeln, dann kann man sich überlegen, was kann man dagegen machen, dass vielleicht das gar nicht ursprünglich aufkommt.
Also sprich, dass die Leute gar nicht das Verlangen mehr haben, andere Leute umzubringen.
Das ist aber ein anderes Thema, das verkauft sich glaube ich nicht gut.
Ja, richtig Komu, klar, natürlich, es wacht keiner morgens auf und sagt, man geht als Leute erschießen.
Von heute auf morgen, das ist über längere Zeit entstanden, da kann die unterschiedlichen Ursachen haben.
Da wenn man nach Norwegen guckt, ich mein, der Breivik in Norwegen, der hat gesagt, er wollte erstens die Regierung treffen und er war gegen die Migrationspolitik in Norwegen.
Das waren so seine Motive, kann man nachlesen auf Wikipedia, wenn das interessiert.
Und was hat er gemacht? Er ist nicht etwa, wo man wieder dran sieht, dass die Welt halt nicht so einfach ist, er ist nicht etwa in irgendeinen Asylbewerberheim gefahren oder so und hat da um sich geschossen, ne.
Er hat eine Autobombe gelegt vor dem Regierungsgebäude in Norwegen und ist dann auf dieses, was war das, ein Zeltlager oder irgendwie sowas von irgendeiner Jugendorganisation gefahren und hat da die Jugendlichen entschossen.
Da waren zum größten Teil Norweger dabei, ich glaube es waren auch ein paar mit Migrationshintergrund dabei, zum größten Teil Norweger.
Also sprich jemand, der den ganz klar rechtsextremen Hintergrund hat, erschießt nicht automatisch Ausländer.
Das ist halt auch wieder was, wo man sieht, es ist halt nicht immer alles sofort klar, was los ist.
Genau, es ist halt schwierig und das ist eigentlich das, wo man nachgucken müsste, warum kommt es dazu?
Warum steht der Typ am Hauptbahnhof und schweißt ein Kind von Zug? Warum läuft der Typ in Hanau am Org?
Das muss man sich genau angucken und wie es dazu gekommen ist und ob man dann was dagegen machen kann.
Wobei die Sache halt ist, wie gesagt, 100%ig sich schützen davor wird man nicht können.
Ja, ich weiß, Knäber.
Also 100%ig schützen oder auch nur annähernd 100%ig schützen kann man sich nicht davor.
Egal, was da irgendwelche Leute in der Politik erzählen, von wegen mehr Vorratsdatensprechung und sonst was, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Entweder kannst du halbwegs frei leben und dich entfalten, wie du willst oder du kannst 100%ig die Leute überwachen und in der Hoffnung sowas auszuschließen.
Da sind wir ja auch schon auf dem Weg hin, aber ich hoffe, das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Und dass die allesamt nicht mehr ganz dicht sind im Kopf, das ist, das haben sie ja zumindest gemeinsam.
Also jemand, der in die Innenstadt geht und im Kaufhaus um sich ballert oder hier à la Huacba sich in die Luft sprengt, die haben alle echt einen absoluten Dachschaden.
Weil du kannst nicht mehr ganz dicht im Kopf sein, dich selbst zu killen für sowas, das geht nicht.
Normal im Hirn sein und sich für irgendwas in die Luft sprengen oder erschießen lassen, das passt nicht zusammen.
Also eins haben sie alle gemein, die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Kommt nachher wieder StarCraft, natürlich.
Immer StarCraft, weißt du ja.
Immer Stream-Outro ist ja immer StarCraft.
Und ich sage für den Twitch Prime-Sub.
Ja, aber wir müssen jetzt mal weitermachen.
War da, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Was hat er denn hier für Schmerzen?
Ah, ich darf da gar nichts reinschreiben.
Okay.
Set.
Der Hype-Train kommt, Leute. Gerade, ein bisschen doofes Thema für den Hype-Train gebe ich zu, was wir gerade hatten.
Der, der, der Jebait-Train ist am Start, das, das Gamaas-Train.
Das Gamaas-Train.
Das Scam-Train.
So, also jetzt schreiben wir was rein, als müssten die Werte exportiert werden.
Oh, oh fuck, ich muss einen Sleep reinmachen, Leute.
Wie lange sleepen wir mal?
10 Sekunden, 5 Sekunden, 5 Sekunden Sleep.
4,9 Sekunden, also 5 ist zu glatt.
So, schauen wir mal.
Vito, da ist es, Leute.
Da ist die Temperatur.
Jetzt können wir da draußen Graf bauen.
Eats.
Jetzt können wir da draußen Graf bauen, so machen wir das.
Compose.
Ach so, Moment, ich muss noch mal, ich muss noch mal, ich muss eine Prometheus-Config mal, ich brauche eine Prometheus-Config.
Config, so ein Beispiel, so ein Beispiel-Config brauche ich mal.
Ah, yes, excellent, excellent, das nehmen wir.
So, und jetzt sagen wir, fuck, ich weiß nicht, wie ging das noch mal.
Wir müssen den Gram jetzt da irgendwie rein mounten und ich weiß nicht wohin.
Speicher Prometheus, ihr selbst nutzt eine Datenbank.
Das hat eine eigene Datenbank, Time-Series-Datenbank dabei.
Das kümmert sich da selbst rum.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Ich muss irgendwie sagen Volumes oder so.
Volumes und jetzt weiß ich aber nicht, wo ich das hin mounten muss.
Also irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, von Lokal, von Lokal Prometheus nach, ja ich weiß nicht wohin.
Von Lokal Prometheus nach, ja ich weiß nicht wohin.
Docker Compose Prometheus Example.
Ja, Volumes, da, das brauchen wir, das brauchen wir.
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Oh mein Gott, so, das da, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt Lokal hier drin einen Ordner.
Der Prometheus heißt es.
Und da kommt die Config-Datei rein, die wir eben hier hatten.
So.
So, und da müssen wir jetzt als Targets noch unseren Exporter dabei schreiben, den da.
Und dann sollte ich in meinem Grafana die Werte von meiner Heizung sehen.
Soweit, in der Theorie hier.
230 Fuhr, huge, pock.
Und alle gucken sich mir zu, wie ich meine Heizung visualisiere.
So, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Lumix sagt, dass ich jetzt in meinem Grafana die Werte von meiner Heizung sehe.
Und alle gucken sich mir zu, wie ich meine Heizung visualisiere.
Lumix sage ich dir gleich was zu, ich will gerade mal schnell gucken, ob es funktioniert hier.
Ah, ich kacke nur, ich habe hier meinen Grafana nicht persistent gemacht.
Dann muss ich den nochmal neu einrichten.
Okay, AdSource, also wir brauchen ProMateChoice9090, save.
Ah, yes, funktioniert.
AliKuluki97 oder Kuluchi97, Max wissen Sie, wie ich aus der Abo-Falle rauskomme?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Das ist zwei Jahre Mindestvertragslaufzeit.
Kann man leider nichts machen.
Ah, du kannst dich an den Twittersupport wenden.
Schickt dein Programm die Daten jetzt an Prometheus oder requestet Prometheus die Daten?
Prometheus pullt, also Prometheus requestet das, Prometheus pullt die Daten.
Was ich auch für die einfachere Sache finde, weil der Server im WLAN dürfte gar nicht an mein Prometheus pushen.
Okay, also wir machen jetzt ein Dashboard und ja, also ich hoffe mal meine, Vito.
Funktioniert nicht.
Warum funktioniert denn das nicht Leute?
Leht, leht er vielleicht die Prometheus-Config gar nicht?
Invalid-Metric-Type.
Oh.
Onks.
Invalid-Metric-Type.
Oh, ich hab irgendwas kaputt gemacht.
Irgendwas ist kaputt.
Irgendwas hab ich kaputt gemacht.
Er sagt, er kann das nicht exportieren.
Warum nicht?
Dann starten wir jetzt mal nur Prometheus und gucken was er macht.
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Was?
Ach so, ja.
Ich bin ja auch blöd.
Hä, warum kann ich das denn rückgängig machen?
Ach stimmt, ja, du hast recht.
Skill-Care, hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht, klar.
So.
Das müssen wir mal gucken.
Was hat er denn verschm- verschm- Invalid-Metric-Type.
Ja.
Was hat er da jetzt für Schmerzen?
Invalid-Metric-Type.
Das funktioniert doch hier alles.
Type.
Ne, ne, ne, nicht im Grafana.
Das ist nur Prometheus zum Einsammeln.
Das funktioniert doch.
Temp.
Target-Temp.
Ha.
Äh, warte mal, ich mach mal die, ich mach mal die, die Curran-Temp, vielleicht ist es irgendwie zu lang oder so, keine Ahnung.
Dann gehorcht jetzt die Mahlstelle, das ist, das weiß ich nämlich nicht.
Das wollte ich gerade mal ausprobieren.
Warten wir mal, bis der hier abgerufen hat.
Wir sind doch nicht bei Grafana, ne, achso, ja fast.
Invalid-Metric-Type.
Hä?
Kann das sein, dass der irgendwas nicht richtig escaped?
Ja, hast du beim Prometheus angegeben, ja ich glaube alle 15 Sekunden.
Ha.
Ich hab das Dashboard nicht auf, das Ding ist aus.
Dann ist es vielleicht alle 5 Sekunden.
Ne, 15.
Ha, was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Kann das sein, dass man das kleinschreiben muss?
Ne, das ist, das ist der Typ hier, das ist der Typ, das, das geht, das hab ich Syntax-Fehler gekriegt, wenn ich das falsch geschrieben hätte.
Ich hab da bestimmt irgendeinen Logik-Fehler drinnen.
Wir machen das mal anders, wir machen das mal anders.
Ich mach den Kram hier raus, ich sag Server Start und ich setze das vorher mal hier irgendwie.
Ähm, wir sagen hier Target, Target temp set gleich 5, irgendwas, so, Start.
Das hier unten funktioniert das doch auch.
Was ich, ich frag, ich mach überhaupt nichts.
Das, was man hier sieht, die Ausgabe, das ist das, was Prometheus so macht. Also das ist nichts, was ich mache, das macht er von sich aus so.
Was soll man mal gucken? Hä? Invalid metric timecode. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Capitals? What? What?
Ist das, ist das ein Bug? Ist das ein, ist das ein Bug in dieser Library vielleicht? Dass die irgendwas ausgeben, was, was nicht sein darf?
Bosch? Aber das hier schreibt es doch auch so. Das hier schreibt er doch auch. Okay, ich hab ne Idee, ich hab ne Idee.
Das liegt bestimmt gar nicht an meinem Zeug. Das liegt gar nicht an meinem Zeug. Das ist bestimmt was, das die Library ist verbackt.
Mensch, Leute, die Library ist verbackt.
Jetzt ist nämlich der Kram von mir raus. Haha, die Library ist verbackt. Das liegt nicht an meinem Zeug.
Okay, so. Ich starte nochmal und gucke, ob es, ob, ob, ob überhaupt irgendwas funktioniert davon.
Hab ich noch irgendwas? Schreibt, ich hab da keinen Einfluss drauf, wie der das schreibt. Das, das, das macht diese komische, ähm, diese, diese Prometheus-Dings-Library für mich.
Ähm, was sei denn, dass die, dass die einfach... Okay, Toysnet. Welche, welche Version haben wir denn hier installiert?
Schaut mal her, vielleicht, vielleicht ist das ein Bug. Äh, Nougat. Aha. 3.5pre. Wisst ihr was? Vinzenema 3.4. Ich bin mir da, ich bin mir da nicht sicher.
Oh, kann ja sein. Ich muss, ich muss Grafana-Persistent machen, ey. Unbedingt. Sonst kriege ich ja Anfälle, wenn ich das jedes Mal neu einrichten muss.
Ich muss oben die Grafana-Persistent machen. Data-Source und Schneunsch. Wie, warum merkt er sich das nicht perfekt? Schneunsch.
Laut GitHub haben die das, hast du mal einen Link zu GitHub? Ich hab hier 3.5pre oder sowas, das letzte, was es gab. Äh, dashboard, add query.
Ich guck gleich mal nach, welche Library-Version ich hab. Ähm, okay,.net. Davon kommt gar nichts an hier, guckt. Da kommt gar nichts an.
Alles was der hier, alles was das Ding exportiert, kommt nicht an.
Ah, ich hab da Prerelease drinnen. Machen wir mal Prerelease weg. Prerelease ist bestimmt, äh, Omega-Lul.
3.4. Prerelease ist bestimmt kaputt. Denn die haben es wahrscheinlich einfach wieder kaputt gemacht.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt ist es kleingeschrieben. Das 3.5 Prerelease ist das Problem. Alter, was ein Crap, ey.
Hallo, ich will. Was ein Crap, ich glaub's net, ey. Kann ich, ich hab nichts falsch gemacht. Ich hab nichts falsch gemacht. Die Library ist einfach kaputt gewesen.
What the fuck, oder? Du hattest uralt-Version. Nee, nee, 1.24 ist was anderes. Ähm, 1.2, das hatte, ich hatte 3.5 Pre. Oder hatte ich wirklich nur uralt-Version 1.25?
Hatte ich echt sowas uraltes? Warum hat der denn sowas 3 Jahre altes installiert? Da steht 1.24. Gibt's das überhaupt? Tatsächlich. Warum hat der 1.24 installiert? What?
Was auch immer, die funktioniert jetzt. Die funktioniert jetzt. Easy as fuck. Hier, Vito. So, jetzt sollte der hier auch nicht mehr rumspacken. Nee, guck, da spackt er auch nicht mehr rum.
Aber das sollte der collecten. Machen wir das hier mal grad zu. Huge, huge dashboard. Wohin, wo löscht man den Kram überhaupt noch mal hier?
Ah, super. Dashboard ist da, aber dashboard not found. So mag ich das. Ok, mal gucken, ob der Kram jetzt funktioniert. Ob der das jetzt abgerufen hat. Ähm, explore können wir da auch machen, ne? Enter, metric. Ähm, wie?
Da ist es, Leute. Da ist die Heizungstemperatur. Warum ist die null? Warum ist die null? Die sollte nicht null sein. Ah, weil ich sie nicht setze. 0W.
Äh, äh, target temp. Ähm, jetzt nochmal. Nochmal neu starten, dann funktioniert's. Stopp.
Ich hab übelst Hunger, Leute. Ich hab hier was zu essen stehen. Ah, yes, jetzt haben wir. Guckt hier, Leute. 55 Grad. Bam. Gucken, ob das stimmt. Gucken, ob das stimmt. Ich ruf das mal hier ab. So, auf der Kommandozeile von dem Ding.
Ach so, das kommt sich jetzt in die Quere, ja. Der kann immer nur eine Sache abfragen gleichzeitig. Muss jetzt mal kurz stoppen, dass ich hier abfragen kann.
Äh, get temp VV ist. Current temp. Ach. Wenn ich jetzt. So, wenn man's mal richtig macht, ja, dann funktioniert's auch. Okay.
So, ähm, warten wir mal bis der abgerufen hat. Sollte jetzt funktionieren. 55 Grad soll. Ist 47 Grad. Sehr gut.
Da, Leute. Hier. 48 Grad. Passt. Gut, dann können wir unser Dashboard machen. Äh, haumt der ganze Mist hier. Kommt mal, kommt mal weg. Ähm, add Dashboard Query. Current temp.
Da ist es, ja. Da ist es. Dann stellen wir das Ganze auf mal 5 Minuten. Wir wollen ja mal was sehen. Dann stellen wir Inter-, Updateintervall stellen wir ein. Auf 5 Sekunden, dass er sich updatet.
Ach, Grafana Speichern. Ja, das mach ich jetzt auch gleich, nachdem ich's richtig einbinde. Wir können's auch gleich speichern. Äh, Name. New Dashboard Copy. Äh, Heizung. Das ist exzellent, exzellent. Äh, Edit. Das Ding kriegt noch eine Name. Äh, Temp. Und jetzt machen wir das noch ein bisschen hübsch. Visualization.
Ach so. Wir geben dem Ding erst mal einen Namen. Das ist die Temp. Das ist Temp. Ähm. Dann machen wir's so. Viel, viel stylischer. Dann kriegt das Ding noch eine extra, extra Farbe. Und zwar, ich mein, das ist eine Temperatur. Ups. Halla. Halla.
Äh, ich mein, das ist Temperatur. Dann machen wir Orange. Oder hier. Bäm. Äh. So, hö. So machen wir's. So. Bis die Heizungstemperatur sinkt. Sehr, sehr nice.
Ist das übrigens immer... Ist das okay, dass das auf 48 steht? 47,7. Jetzt müssen wir nur mal gucken, ob sich der Wert ändert. Aber der sollte sich eigentlich ändern. Alle fünf Sekunden ruft der hier ab.
Sieht man ja auch hier. Alle fünf Sekunden ruft der ab. Und... Ach so, du solltest den Grafana-Container speichern. Oh, das hab ich verkackt. Das hab ich verkackt. Das hätt ich vorher machen müssen.
Ich kann das Dashboard vielleicht exportieren oder so. Oder Config irgendwie abziehen.
Moin, Patrick. Gut. Jetzt müssen wir einfach mal abwarten. Aktuell ist halt die Heizung nur mal 48 Grad. Und die ist halt die ganze Zeit 48 Grad, 47 Grad, irgendwas.
Äh. Kann man hier irgendwie einstellen, dass der Dezimalstellen macht? Unit. Unit. Ähm. Celsius. Scale. Äh. Oh. Kann man dem irgendwie Dezimals... Ah, hier. Fünf.
Also wirklich... Ah, doch. Guck mal, Leute. Doch, doch, doch. Das updatet sich hier. Guck mal. Das updatet sich.
Erstmal fünf Nachkommastellen. Klar. Exzellent. Will er sehen, wenn sich das ändert. Aber es ändert sich ein bisschen wenig, oder? Sind das immer? Ja, das sind immer 47,01. 47,01. 47,5. Moment, warum ist da 47,5 nicht drin? Exportiert er das doch nicht richtig?
Wir sehen es gleich ein bisschen besser skaliert. Sobald Null und das da weg ist. Dann sehen wir es gleich ein bisschen besser skaliert.
Wir saven das Dashboard jetzt erstmal. Dann gehen wir hier rein und sagen Start Dashboard ist... What?
Hä? Warum kann ich Heizung nicht als Start Dashboard auswählen? Muss ich das vorher irgendwie favorisieren oder was? Hä?
Wenn der Container rebootet ist alles weg. Dann dürfen wir den Container einfach nicht rebooten. Ah, jetzt ist es ein bisschen... Jetzt hat es sich geändert ein bisschen.
Wir dürfen einfach den Container nicht rebooten.
Warum hat er hier so... Ich meine er fragt alle 15 Sekunden ab, aber der aktualisiert nicht alle 15 Sekunden.
Ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das wild wäre. Ich kann damit leben. Aber eine Sache müssen wir noch machen. Wir müssen die andere Temperatur da noch reinhauen.
Wir brauchen nämlich noch die Solltemperatur. Und die Solltemperatur... Hallo? Die soll er da oben als Strich anzeigen. Da müssen wir mal gucken wie wir das machen.
Die Heizung rundet halt nicht. Die Werte sind hier unterschiedlich. Aber was natürlich sein kann ist, dass der Exporter... Der Exporter kriegt das ja nur alle 5 Sekunden.
Der exportiert das nur und ich weiß nicht wie oft das Grafana das abruft. Das müssen wir mal schauen. Ich werde jetzt erstmal das andere machen, dass es ein bisschen hübscher ist.
Das ist alles grad. Die Target Temperatur die kriegt...
Ich will dem sagen, dass der... Ich will dem sagen, dass der nur... Man konnte ihm doch irgendwie sagen, dass der statt einer Linie Striche macht. Das ging doch irgendwie.
Dann... Ah! Genau. So will ich das haben. Ah, yes. Exzellent. So ist das gut. Jetzt will ich noch, dass es gestrichelt ist. Dash.
Ich kann nicht ihm sagen, dass es gedashed ist. Ich auch noch. Ich will, dass es gestrichelt ist.
Nee, Bas. Bas ist hier. Das ist... Exzellent. Aber guckt mal hier. Er kriegt die Schwankungen mit hier. Dashes an sich bringt nichts. Dashes und dann was? True? Ah, yes. Sehr gut. Safe.
Ja, das ist doch das, das gefällt mir. Das ist schick. Die Farben... Ja, das ist nice. Dem Ding müssen wir noch eine andere Farbe geben.
Der kriegt andere Color. Kriegt grün oder sowas. Color. Change. Good. Grün.
Blau. Rot. Rot. Kein Pogu. Wie? Ich hab keinen Pogu drinne. Kann nicht sein. Line Whip. Ah. So ist das gut. So gefällt mir das. Nice. GG.
Jetzt kann ich bei einer Heizung zugucken, wie sie bei 47,5 Grad rumgammelt. Aber man sieht, da kriegt die Änderung schon mit. 47,9. 47,7.
Warum geht die nicht auf die 55? Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil die nicht hinterher kommt. Wieso heizt die nicht mehr? Ich glaub, die kommt nicht hinterher.
Ich glaub, die kommt nicht hinterher, das ganze Haus zu heizen. Ich hab die heute noch nie über 47 Grad gesehen. Oder 48.
Was ist das für eine Heizung? Das ist eine Wiesmann Vito Dens 222. Aber man sieht ja hier. Brenner Start. Soll ist. Hier kann man ja auch zugucken.
Ich glaube, wir könnten da noch jede Menge mehr Sachen einbauen. Aktuell macht er ja nur Solltemp und aktuelle Temperatur. Man könnte die alles andere auch abfragen lassen.
Aktuell ist es halt sehr unspektakulär. Es schwankt halt zwischen 47 und 47,5 und 47,9. Hat die auch RGB. Ich könnte dem Raspberry unten ein paar LEDs dranhängen.
Ja, das würde wohl funktionieren. Okay, sehr schick. Sehr schick.
Ich weiß, was wir machen können. Wir können einfach mal hier schalten auf 24 Stunden. Dann ist die Skalierung nämlich anders.
Wartet mal. Wir haben 15 Minuten. Genau. Also man sieht schon, dass der kann schon unterschiedliche Sachen anzeigen und sich unterschiedlich updaten.
Ich weiß noch, was wir machen. Eine Sache sollten wir vielleicht noch machen. Edit und zwar eine Legende einfügen. Rechts.
Und dann machen wir die Nachkommastellen weg. Die braucht doch keiner. Kann es sein, dass das zu blöd ist, die vor zu aktualisieren.
Warum ist eine Nachkommastelle, zwei Nachkommastellen? Versteht das irgendjemand, die Logik?
Kannst du auch abrufen, ob der Brenner läuft? Ja klar kann ich das abrufen. Das müssen wir nur noch einbauen.
Wir machen mal 10 Minuten. Ach nee, geht nicht. Wir warten einfach, bis das hier rausgelaufen ist.
Hier war am Anfang, wo es angelaufen ist. Das funktioniert.
Sehr schön. Exzellent. Aktualisiert alle 5 Sekunden. Läuft durch. Der Unterschied ist jetzt relativ marginal gerade.
47, 47.5, 47.5, 47.5. Soll ich vielleicht mal den Abfrageintervall hochstellen? Wobei es macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Warum nicht BTO? Hör mal auf. Gut, Brennerstatus. Ja, machen wir, machen wir. Das bauen wir jetzt noch schnell ein in Brennerstatus.
Was machen wir? Ach, hier haben wir doch. Get Brenner Starts. Was heißt Get Brenner Starts und Get Brenner Status?
Die Benamung ist wirklich hochgradig exzellent von dem Zeug. Get Betriebsart, Get Brenner Starts, Get Brenner Status. Exquisite.
Get Brenner Status können wir noch einbauen. Genau, hier unten haben wir nämlich hier. Also, dann machen wir das jetzt hier, Rob.
Ja, Brenner Status. Ist das ein Bull? Ist das an oder aus? Oder kann Brenner Status auch 30% oder so sein?
Ich weiß es nicht. Get Brenner, Get Brenner Status. Brenner ist normal für an oder aus, ja.
Ja gut, dann sagen wir jetzt hier Get, Brenner Status, Brenner, nee, Starts, Status, Brenner Status.
Da muss ich mir jetzt erstmal gucken. Da muss ich jetzt erstmal wieder ausmachen hier. Mal schauen, was da als Ergebnis zurückkommt.
Erstmal schauen, was da für Unterschiede daraus kommen. Da brauchen wir noch eine neue Metrik. Nämlich ein, äh, was, wie nennen wir das Ding?
Ich will das nicht Brenner Status nennen. Fire. State. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie nennen wir das Ding dann? Burner State.
Afterburner. State. State. Ich nenne es einfach mal Status. Mir fällt noch gerade nichts. Fire? Das klingt doof. Das klingt als würde es brennen.
Leute, ich hab Hunger. Ich nenne das jetzt mal einfach Status, weil ich muss jetzt was essen und da müssen wir uns ein YouTube-Futtervideo angucken.
Fire. Ich weiß nicht. Ich schreibe da jetzt mal irgendwas rein. Ich will einfach das jetzt eintragen und gut essen.
Oh, ich bin auch ein Kacknoob. Hier oben hätte ich das schon ordentlich nennen müssen. Ich nenne es jetzt einfach Status.
So, und jetzt mal gucken. Ah, das ist ja auch kein Bull. Äh, wenn das ein Bull ist. Ich muss das gar nicht setzen. Ich will es einfach nur ausführen.
Weil ich gucken will, was da als Antwort kommt, dass ich weiß, wie ich das parsen muss. Hier, da. Hast du es gesehen? Das da kommt zurück.
Also, was? 32%? Okay, das ist doch kein Bull. Das kann das wohl in Prozent. Also, kriegt es jetzt einen Byte. Das reicht. So. U-Byte. Gibt es so was?
Das reicht. Für 0-100 ist genug. So, okay. Also, jetzt haben wir das Result. Das müssen wir jetzt parsen. Und zwar splitten wir es am Punkt, würde ich sagen.
Nachkommastellen gibt es nicht in dem Fall. Brenner? Na doch, kann doch sein, ob der Brenner auf volle Pulle läuft oder nicht.
Äh, wir splitten es am Punkt, nehmen das erste und dann sagen wir Return, Pars, Result. Gut. So. Und jetzt sollte das funktionieren.
Den Status Set. Jetzt sollte der den Brenner Status exportieren. Der Brenner moduliert. Okay. Get Brenner Status. 32.
Na gut, jetzt haben wir natürlich keine Werte gerade. Das hat ihn jetzt verwirrt. Das hat ihn jetzt hochgradig verwirrt, dass wir ausgeschaltet haben zwischendurch.
So. Also. Neuer Graph. Add Panel. Vito. Status. Da ist es doch. Der Brenner Status. 32 Prozent sind wir jetzt.
Ähm. Brenner. Brenner. Ich nenne das jetzt einfach Brenner. Gut, Brenner. Legende, aber rechts.
Unit, äh, Percent. Gut, das war es schon. Save. Also Titel. Brenner.
Sehen wir auch, ob der Brenner an oder aus ist. Da sind wir noch auf 32 Prozent. Würste der Status sicher auf 100 Prozent sein. Vielleicht wird es sonst zu warm. Wer weiß, wer weiß, was das da so treibt.
Zumindest müssen wir jetzt sehen, dass sich das aktualisiert mit der Zeit hier. Alles, was wir hier schon sehen, ja. Temperatur passt. Das ist die Soll Temperatur, die ist halt nicht so, nicht so ganz erreicht. Der Brenner brennt.
Ja, 32 Prozent. Dann warten wir mal ab. Gucken wir der Sache mal zu.
Das gefällt mir. Das ist doch sehr praktisch. Da sind wir noch 100 Prozent. So Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Wir gucken jetzt ein Futtervideo und danach gucken wir uns nochmal den Graf an. Gucken wir mal meinen Lieblings Food, meinen Lieblings Food Channel. Kann man dann hier zu bieten.
Du hast ein gutes Futtervideo. Oh nee. Ganz bestimmt nicht. Wenn ich den Titel schon lese.
Oh nee, das ist ja aber nicht. Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Spicy Teobumba, was auch immer. Pakistan Meat Feast Street Food Tour, Ägypten Seafood Market, Ägypten Barbecue. Taugt ägyptisches Essen, Leute?
Ich glaube ich habe noch nie was Ägyptisches gegessen. Breakfast sieht lecker aus. Nice, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ägyptisches Barbecue oder Cambodian Breakfast? Was ist das für ein Land überhaupt? Kampotja?
Cambodia auf Deutsch. Kampotja, doch? Einfach weil es Barbecue ist.
Sieh leise. Das sieht halt ziemlich runtergekommen aus im Vergleich zu den asiatischen Sachen.
Ich will das Essen sehen, ich will das Essen sehen. Was ist das?
Oh, das gefällt mir nicht. Ich brauche was anderes. Irgendwas. Das gefällt mir alles nicht. Oh, was ist das? Ägyptische Grills.
Nee, nee, da wird nicht so viel gefuttert. Die labern mehr in dem Video, das ist nix. Dann gucken wir uns doch das Breakfast an.
Das sieht doch schon mal besser aus. Ich weiß zwar nicht was es ist. Würde ich jetzt auch alles futtern.
So, ich esse mal was Leute. Ich mache mal das Mikrofon ein bisschen weg, dass ich euch nicht so sehr ins Ohr schmatze.
Das würde ich jetzt lieber essen. Das würde ich jetzt lieber essen als zwei Stückchen Brot hier.
Was sagt ihr? Würde dieses Essen gut zu meinem Weinkeller passen? Ich finde schon.
Das ist irgendwie zu leise wieder. Ist der alte Mann ein Sklaven? Das bin ich.
Das Fleisch ist der beste Teil. Schaut euch das an. Die Texture. Oh mein Gott, ich hätte eine leichte Eier auf dem Topf bekommen.
Was ist das für ein Schwammelding? Okay, das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Habt ihr gesehen was das war?
Das war quasi ein gekochtes Stück Blutwurst. Mit wenig Wurst drin. Das war auch nicht mein Fall.
Wo gibt es Essen? Ich brauche Essen. Ah, jetzt Essen.
Das sieht aus wie ein riesengroßer Glückskeks. Oder? Ich finde es sieht aus wie ein riesengroßer Glückskeks, auch von der Wölbung her.
Okay, ohne Sesam. Ich bin kein großer Dipper. Einzige was gedippt wird sind vielleicht Pommes Frites in Mayonnaise oder so.
Ich mag Gedippe nicht. Aber das sieht gut aus.
Mario, ich trinke auch keinen Kaffee.
Bacon Strips, Bacon Strips, Bacon Strips.
Ich frage mich bei seinen Videos immer, was die Leute im Hintergrund sich denken. Weil er sitzt da rum immer in den Restaurants, Equipment am Start, Riesentisch und alle gucken sie nicht hin.
Ich würde es echt lieber essen als mein Essen.
Ich würde es echt lieber essen als mein Abendessen.
Es ist wirklich salzig, aber so ein schöner, riecherischer Geschmack. Je mehr ich esse, desto größer ist mein Glück.
We got a green curry noodle and a red curry noodle. So this is the green curry. Banana flour, cucumber, the yellow is a sandwich and this is sugar.
That's bloody insane. It's a thicker curry, so it grabs onto that noodle extremely, extremely well. I'm not usually a fan of banana flour, because I feel like it tastes like you bit into a banana peel.
But here, the crunch of it actually goes pretty well with this curry. This curry itself is amazingly delicious. It's so smooth, a little creamy. Gonna add the spice, a little citrus on the lime.
This is so aromatic and coconutty. You can add the chilies in an entire bit. That's not for beginners, trust me.
The red curry is sweeter, sweeter for sure. I feel like, I think this one better. Nice crunch from the sprouts, the cucumbers and everything. And the curry is a little less creamy. The curry is absorbed by the noodles so well. This is such a flavorful noodle dish.
The noodle texture is gonna be a little softer than you'll find at one of the big noodle places, but that flavor is unbeatable. Let's come here and get one of each. This is one of my favorite things in this country. Oh my god. These little coconutty, fluffy cupcakes with coconut milk on top.
This thing, if you love anything that's fluffy and sweet and extremely, extremely aromatic, this is your jam. This is just really the fluffiest, airiest, bounciest, the coconutiest cake you can find in the land.
But it tastes pretty good. It probably really tastes pretty good.
Let's just walk around and see these ladies with like a thousand little cups and a steamer. That's what they're cooking. Get you some. So the area that we were in is actually called the Old Market. So this is an area where right early in the morning you got noodle vendors, you got meat, grilled meats, rice, everything you could ever want for your day.
Die wissen wie man eigentlich frühstückt, äh, nicht irgendwie ein komisches Brötchen, sondern erstmal so ein richtig schönes Stück Fleisch und Nudelsuppe, äh.
We can find it here. I mean this is still early in the day and everybody is in town.
They don't do a lot of cooking at home so most of the stuff is just bought on the street so these vendors get a lot of business from people just showing up, grabbing something for work, for school or you know after work, coming home, grab something on the way. I love that culture. I love it. Cheap and good and fast. And you don't have to do the dishes.
Wait, this is the one stopped by the French. And it's green but it's actually really sweet.
Ich brauch Essen, Leute. Ich brauch Essen.
Wo ist Essen? Essen. Die Oma macht bestimmt gutes Essen.
Was der aber am Tag alles futtert, der Kerl.
Most Asian countries you go to, they're gonna have their own version of congee. In China, the congee in the north is sweet, congee in the south is savory, everywhere else in Asia is all savory.
Man, this one has a mixed meat, pork belly, heart, liver.
Alter, was das? Das würd ich im Leben nicht essen. Da weiß der nicht was.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Corona-intensiv-falls.
Weil was futtert der alles an einem Tag, das ist ja unglaublich.
ETF.
Ah, das ist eher was für mich hier.
Das ist Schweidefüße? Was? Nee.
Das sieht nur so aus wie Schweidefüße. Hat mit Schweidefüße nichts zu tun.
Ist das frittiert? Garantiert.
Was ich bei dem Channel mag, ist, ich kann es normalerweise überhaupt nicht ab, wenn man Leute schmatzen hört. Also den meisten Leuten kann ich nicht beim Essen zugucken.
Bei ihm hab ich keine Probleme.
Hauptsache frittiert.
Terroristenarm.
Moment, was ist es jetzt? Fisch oder Banane?
Es ist wirklich großartig, sehr, sehr, sehr krispig auf der Außenseite. Einen gebratenen Bananen und einen Tuk-Tuk.
Ist es wieder mehr lokal als das? Oh mein Gott, du hörst das Krümchen?
Ich meine, es ist laut hier. Auf den Straßen, mit Autos überall, Konstruktion, aber du solltest frittieren.
Es ist krass, was der am Tag alles isst, oder?
Oder er betet uns und es sind drei Tage und er zieht einfach nur immer das gleiche Hemd an, was wir denken, es ist ein Tag.
Ich meine, es ist einfach super voller Fleisch, fast, darf ich sagen, zu voller, wenn es so ein Ding ist. Ich fühle mich, als wäre das eine affirmative Aktion von Vegetablen. Ist das hier für Statistiken?
Das Fleisch sieht unglaublich lecker aus. Oh, das ist ein verrückter Fleischstuhl. Oh mein Gott.
Einige Beobachtungen. Das Fleisch wird nicht der größte Zünder, den du jemals gehabt hast. Warte mal, es gibt verschiedene Teile von Fleisch hier drin.
Dieses Zünder wird viel leckeres Fleisch und Tendenz haben. Oh mein Gott.
Das wird mir jetzt auch geben.
Das ist fast zu viel guter Fleisch. Das ist definitiv etwas, das man mit Nudeln essen sollte, mit ein wenig Karbe, ein wenig Starch, darf ich sagen.
Es ist einfach ein bisschen zu lecker. Es ist einfach eine riesige Zucht von Fleisch. Das ist es. Oh mein Gott.
Aber heisst du in den Knochen rein? Das ist ein Stück Apfel. Hat sich vielleicht zu angehört.
Deswegen wollte ich eigentlich das Mikrofon ein bisschen wegmachen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so meh.
Also bald rein, meiner in der Regel auch nicht. Gibt ein paar Ausnahmen. Aber wahnsinnig viel Fisch muss ich auch nicht futtern.
Außer lustigerweise, ich habe ja lange kein Fisch gegessen, aber Sushi habe ich gefuttert. Also kein normalen Fisch, aber rohen Fisch in Sushi-Form habe ich gefuttert.
Mittlerweile bin ich ein bisschen, ja, ein bisschen mehr standard angekommen.
So etwas wie Lachs kann ich mittlerweile auch futtern. Aber am liebsten esse ich tatsächlich rohen Fisch beim Sushi.
Oh Leute, fertig essen.
Die frittieren alles habe ich das Gefühl. Ich glaube es war nicht frittiert.
Aber ich habe noch nie einen, der traditionell gefeiert wurde.
Das ist das, was ich gelesen habe. Der Curry sollte fast wie eine Pasta-Konsistenz sein.
Und der erste, den ich hatte, war mehr waterig. Es ist weniger waterig, es ist mehr dick, aber es ist noch nicht so, wie ich es gedacht hätte.
Ich glaube, es ist ein guter Dicht, aber ich glaube, dass es noch etwas fehlt, zumindest für mich, das das in den legendären Status macht.
Warst du schon in Niederlanden? Ich habe zwei Halbbrüder in den Niederlanden.
Aber mit denen habe ich nichts zu tun. Null. Nee, war ich noch nicht.
Nein, nein, das kann ich nicht.
So, ich gehe mal kurz in meinen Weinkeller. Schauen wir mal, was der Graf macht.
Es funktioniert, seht ihr es. Es funzt. Der Brenner, der Brenner brennt. Der Brenner geht ziemlich oft an und wieder aus.
Meinst du, wenn der Brenner auf 100% ist, dann brennt das? Das wäre aber schlecht.
Es funktioniert. Eine Sache können wir noch mal ausprobieren. Edit.
Irgendwie ist meine. Wir stellen das hier noch mal ein auf.
Durchschnittlich.
Ebel ist angenehmer zu gucken. Silvertag. Drei Monate. Dankeschön. Huge Sub.
Dass ich das nicht irgendwie aus dem Container ziehen muss. Magst du dein Lieblings-Sushila in Frankfurt verraten?
Muss ich mal kurz drüber nachdenken, welcher das überhaupt ist.
Das dashboard exportieren. Das dashboard exportieren ist doch einfach nur ein Link dazu, oder? Ach so. Echt? Okay.
So? Aha. Ich kann mich auch einfach connecten in den Container und das ganze abziehen.
Ja, also lass mal überlegen. Mein Lieblings-Sushiladen aus Frankfurt. Wo hat es mir am besten geschmeckt?
Schön hier zu sagen. So wirklich riesig, so wirklich überragend, viel viel besser als alle andere.
Hätten wir da jetzt eigentlich keine Ahnung. Wir gehen eigentlich nur in drei verschiedene Läden, weil die recht nah sind.
Ich komme aus Frankfurt. Genauso komme ich aus Hanau. Wo es letztens so abging.
Kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen, was mein Lieblingsladen ist? Die Frage war komplizierter als ich gedacht habe.
Doch, ich weiß, was mein Lieblingsladen ist. Der wo man mit iPads bestellt. Ich weiß aber nicht wie der heißt.
Da war ich auch noch zweimal, aber das war richtig gut. Was? Oishi? Echt Oishi?
Was? Nee, das sah anders aus. Gibt man den Laden da vielleicht auch?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Nee, ich weiß nicht wie der heißt. Aber der ist wirklich cool gewesen.
Das war all you can eat Sushi und man konnte allerdings, es war halt nichts, was im Kreis läuft, sondern man konnte all you can eat orderen. Das war ganz gut. Man konnte auch die richtig teuren Sachen orderen. Dafür war es relativ teuer. Dafür hat es 30 Euro gekostet.
Mittags ist es halt ordentlich. Geht noch deutlich teurer.
Weißt du, wie man Port Crabber oder generell so Bots blocken kann, wenn die auf meinem EngineX Web Server zu Hause aufschlagen? Warum kommen Bots bei dir auf dem EngineX Server raus? Hast du da nicht irgendeine Authentifizierung davor oder sowas?
Du kannst sowas hier machen. Du kannst sowas hier nehmen. Das ist so eines der Klassiker, um Leute zu blocken. Aber am besten ist, du machst eine Authentifizierung davor, dann schlägt keiner mehr wirklich bei dir auf.
Also im Lock vielleicht noch, ja, aber gut. Ansonsten nimmst du Feltube an, wenn du da Leute loswerden willst.
Was? Ja, Omi. Ich glaube. Nee. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das sieht auch anders aus. Ich weiß nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Lulvi. Korean Barbecue. Habe ich bei uns noch keinen gescheiten Laden gefunden, leider.
Was? Frankfurt Sakai. Wow. Okay, das ist eher so ein Event Ding, oder? Da kriege ich, da könnte ich gar nicht sitzen.
Da könnte ich gar nicht sitzen, richtig. Das wäre mir zu anstrengend. Das wäre mir zu anstrengend, mich da auf die Erde zu sitzen.
Außerdem sieht das auch aus, wie als wäre es sehr teuer und es gibt sehr wenig Sachen. Ja, genau so sieht das aus.
Es ist wahrscheinlich saumäßig teuer und es gibt wenig dafür. Also ich bevorzuge beim Essen so eine Mischung.
Ich habe gerne viel und es muss auch ordentlich schmecken. Dafür bezahle ich dann auch was. Das ist gut, das bezahle ich dann auch gern.
Aber was ich überhaupt nicht mag ist, wenn es so kleine dafür super abgedrehte Sachen gibt.
So etwas wie das hier, das ist mir zu wenig. Guck mal, der Brenner, der geht ja nur an und aus die ganze Zeit.
Das kann doch eben was nicht stimmen, oder?
Serious Max, was hast du für ein Video geschickt? Mach das jetzt einfach mal auf.
Was? 10 Ways Linux ist Better.
Mal gucken, da kann ich mal einen Senf dazu abgeben. Und in der Zwischenzeit können wir noch mal die Heizung später zugucken.
Schrei nicht so Linux. Linux, das heißt übrigens nicht Linux, aber egal. Aber, aber, aber, aber.
Weiter.
Hat er nicht letztens ein Video gemacht, das er aufhören will? War da nicht irgendwas?
Oh Gott, World of Warships, hör mal auf.
Guck mal drauf an. Wenn ich einen Red Hat haben will, dann kostet er doch Geld.
Also ein richtig echtes, offizielles Red Hat mit offiziellen Red Hat Repos. Dann kostet das Geld.
Ja, deswegen macht unter Linux auch wirklich jeder was er will.
Also unter Linux, das ist Vor- und Nachteil zugleich. Es macht jeder was er will. Und dementsprechend, man sieht es schon an Kommando Zeilen Tools.
Ich sag nur Minus Minus Version, Version, Minus Version, Minus V, Version, was es sonst noch alles gibt. Macht halt jeder ein bisschen was er will.
Ja, FFmpeg ist glaube ich sogar Minus Minus Help, was die Versionsnummer mit ausgibt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, ganz klar. Ja.
Also im Vergleich zu Windows ist das Paketmanagement unter Linux meilenweit vorne.
Ich meine unter Windows gibt es kein Paketmanagement so richtig, außer den Windows Store und der Windows Store ist halt der Windows Store.
Mario Trader mit der Pleading Edge Copypasta, die ist ja ganz neu. Wo hast du die denn her Mario? Die ist erst zwei Wochen alt.
Ist ja auch so, ist ja auch so.
Also das ist im Vergleich zu Windows halt ein riesen Unterschied.
In der Regel kernel update gleich Reboot.
Allerdings ganz so stimmt das auch nicht. Die meisten Dinge haben irgendeinen Microcontroller.
Aktuell haben die ganzen China Hardware, die haben ja zum größten Teil den ESP866 drauf, weil das sich von den Features her gut passt.
Da läuft kein Linux drauf. Also ja viele viele Geräte wo man nicht damit rechnet haben Linux drauf.
Aber bei einem Toaster glaube ich eher nicht.
Ja aber ihr macht doch keine Toaster oder?
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber dafür ist man wirklich auf GDI und Verderben davon abhängig, dass sich irgendjemand drum kümmert.
Also klar kannst du unter Windows auch sagen, wenn die Hersteller keinen Bock mehr haben das ganze einstellen ist okay. Aber ich will nicht wissen wie viele unfertige Sachen unter Linux im Umlauf sind.
So nach dem Motto da hat mal irgendwo einer was zusammen gehackt. 60 Prozent der Funktion des Gerätes, 60 Prozent der Sachen funktionieren und jetzt hat er keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Das ist unter Linux kommt das schon oft vor. Also umgedreht ist besser. Man muss eigentlich bevor man sich das kauft gucken, dass die Hardware gut passt.
Chancen sind heute relativ gut, dass out of the box alles läuft.
Yes sir, once configured and running barring a power outage or other catastrophic event, lttstore.com, Linux will probably sell out as good as running.
In der Theorie, ja und es ist der einzige ordentliche Grafikkartentreiber für Linus, wenn man Performance haben will.
Das ist so, ja.
Kommt drauf an in welcher Community.
Also man sollte nicht in das Gentoo Forum gehen und was doofes fragen zum Beispiel.
Ich habe euch ja schon mal absolut mind blowing Sachen revealed hier im Stream.
Jetzt soll ich mal aufgefallen, dass bei, ich sag jetzt mal für die Leute die nicht da waren, soll ich schon mal aufgefallen, dass das bei virtuellen Desktops das einzige was nicht virtuell ist, der Desktop ist.
Alles ändert sich, nur der Desktop nicht. Warum nennt man das dann virtuelle Desktops?
Der Rest ändert sich, aber der Desktop ändert sich nicht. Es müsste eher virtuelle Taskleiste oder so heißen.
Aber, ist das nicht Einstellungs Sache? Nee. Das stimmt. Aber Linux waren auch nicht die ersten. Also so ziemlich alles was man in X drauf hatte, konnte das schon ewig.
Ja Patrick, dann frag sie mal ob Ubuntu oder Ubuntu.
Obwohl wir wissen es ja, wir haben uns ja das Video schon angeguckt.
Was mich ja echt verstört hat ist, wir haben uns ja ein Video angeguckt, wo Nelson Mandela höchstpersönlich gesagt hat Ubuntu und in dem Video war ein Ubuntu Logo.
Und das Ubuntu von Nelson Mandela hat mit Ubuntu Lilux überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das hat mich verwundert. Was das eine mit dem anderen, warum?
Aber wir haben die Aussprache gehört, es heißt definitiv Ubuntu und nicht Ubuntu.
Ja, aber High DPI Displays kriegen wir immer noch nicht hin.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Ein Dash verwendet keiner. Dash ist eine Shell für Scripts. Sie ist nicht als interaktive Shell gedacht. Das müsste eher FISH, ZSH und BASH sein.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Da hat er noch Jabber am Start.
Der hat aber sein Desktop definitiv nicht so schön gepimpt wie mein Desktop, oder? Also ich finde das doch echt hübsch mit den Icons da oben.
Hat jemand schon mal aus dem Wirt SH KVM gemacht? Meine fette 4HE-Kiste hier hinten läuft seit Jahren schon mit KVM. Aber ich hab mich da drum herum gedrückt mit Wirt SH zu machen.
Ich hab das alles mit dem, bis auf ein paar Kleinigkeiten, mit dem Wirt Manager gemacht. Einfach den Wirt Manager weitergeleitet über SSH oder den Wirt Manager lokal auf meinem Lilux installiert und über SSH connected.
Das hat mit Lilux auch nicht so viel zu tun. Oh, jawoll, jawoll, der hat jetzt gefehlt.
Stelman freut das ganze jetzt.
Bis halt auf die Sachen, die man nicht in seinem Heimatverzeichnis konfiguriert. Die sind natürlich nicht dann.
Ich habe eine kuriosität. Anthony hat sogar einen Typen von System76 gemacht, der einen Skript von GitHub downloaden konnte, der alle Software installieren und seinen User Profile downloaden konnte.
Das kann man machen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ich kann allen nur empfehlen, sich den Lilux-VM zu machen. Dann spart man sich 0 Boot, dann hat man ein System, mit dem man sich auskennt noch unten drunter und wenn man spielen will und sonstige Sachen machen will, braucht man E-Windows.
Ich kann jedem nur empfehlen, sich eine VM anzulegen. Man lernt wirklich viel.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Auf Reddit muss ich sagen, sind die Lilux-Leute wirklich hilfsbereit zum größten Teil. Ich würde halt nicht im Gento-Forum fragen.
Man kriegt im Vergleich zu früher natürlich mehr zum Laufen, aber das ist absolut kein Vergleich zu Windows.
Trotz Proton und den ganzen Anstrengungen, das auch teilweise in Steam drin ist, das wird in nächster Zeit nichts.
Es wird erst was, wenn die Spiele nicht um Umwege auf Linux laufen, sondern Linux-Support von Haus aus mit dabei ist.
Wenn es mal irgendwann heißt, Xbox, Playstation, Windows, Linux, dann werden Spiele gut laufen, vorher nicht. Alles andere sind ekliche Hacks vorher und das funktioniert nicht.
Zum Beispiel alles, was Anti-Cheat verwendet, kannst du in der Lilux klicken. CS mag da wahrscheinlich technisch gut laufen, finde ich das neueste Game, allerdings alles, was Anti-Cheat braucht, ist schon mal zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Und auch viele neuen Sachen funktionieren mehr schlecht als recht. Ich fände es auch gut, wenn das unter Linux funktionieren würde, ohne dass man sich Gedanken machen muss.
Aber da ist noch ein langer Weg hin, das wird in nächster Zeit nicht passieren. Ja, das sehe ich auch so, dass sich das einfach nicht lohnt.
Ich weiß, dass Linux nicht mehr Ansatzweise hat. Wahrscheinlich sind wir sogar noch im Verhältnis, wenn man alles unter einem Prozent dabei nimmt. Selbst dann lohnt sich das Ganze nicht.
Weißt du, ich kann quasi eine Sache machen, habe 80% der Leute und ich muss nochmal einen riesen Aufwand betreiben, um eine Handvoll Leute zu erreichen. Das lohnt sich halt einfach nicht.
Mal gucken, was die Heizung macht. Der Brenner, Leute, der Brenner brennt. Seht ihr das? Der Brenner gibt alles. Der Brenner gibt alles.
Huge, huge burn. Betakte mal den Brenner. Gute Idee, ja. Und guckt hier, die Temperatur geht auch hoch. Brenner gibt Gas, Temperatur.
Afterburner. Gibt die Heizung direkt die Daten über SNMP oder hast du da einen Sensor dran?
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi dran. Über ein optisches USB-Kabel zu einem proprietären Herstelleranschluss. Und auf dem Raspberry Pi habe ich was laufen, was ich abfrage.
Der Brenner, der will es jetzt aber gerade voll wissen, oder? Volle Kanne. Gleich kommt die Heizung an mir vorbei geflogen. Ich sehe es schon.
Wie viele Chrome Tabs?
Ach so, Lumix, genau. Warte mal, was gab es? Was hast du vorhin nochmal gefragt? Ich weiß, ich habe gesagt, Lumix, ich sage was zu. Aber ich habe das voll verdrängt.
Was hast du denn gefragt nochmal? Paste das einfach nochmal rein. Was hältst du von MQTT? Das ist super. Für das, wofür es da ist, ist das super.
MQTT ist top. Doch das einzige, was es gibt in dieser Richtung. Ja, Lumix, ich beantworte das. Du musst es bloß nochmal schreiben, ich sehe es im Chat nicht mehr.
MQTT, genau. Was ist mit dem Brenner los? Oh, guck mal Leute. Er geht wieder langsam runter.
Ja. Lumix fragt, wie ich am besten ein Webinterface mit Slidern und Switches, was auf JavaScript basiert, zum Laufen bringen als Anfänger.
Du meinst, worauf du das hosten kannst, oder was? Da musst du etwas spezifischer fragen, um was genau willst du wissen.
So wie man sowas programmiert, geht es darum, wenn man es programmiert hat, worauf man es laufen lässt. Brauchst du das passende Backend dafür?
Das kann man jetzt so nicht beantworten.
Wie hast du das mit KVM, das mit dem Network gemacht? Hast du die VMs auch per Bridge gemacht? Ja, ich habe alle VMs auf mein physisches Interface gebridged, weil die alle intern im gleichen Netz hängen.
Ich glaube, MacVTab war das, was ich genommen habe. Alle auf mein physisches Interface und GoodIs.
Ich meine, nur den Tipp, wie man das mit Backend und Frontend-Integration angeht, vielleicht noch Ideen für Framework.
Wenn du etwas Simples machen willst, würde ich es ganz ohne Frameworks machen, also im Frontend. Dann würde ich einfach plain JavaScript machen.
Wenn du wirklich nur ein paar Buttons willst, und da soll etwas passieren, dann würde ich plain JavaScript machen. Dann musst du nämlich nicht noch irgendein Framework dabei lernen.
Backend hosten, am einfachsten dürfte das sein. Wenn du wirklich nur etwas ganz Simples haben willst, nimmst du das hier.
Hast du ein Python Flask Backend? Das ist alles, was du brauchst. Oder du machst ein Node.js Backend. Das ist auch ziemlich simpel.
Aber ich finde, so zum Einstieg ist Glass so ziemlich das Simpelste, was man machen kann. Da muss man sich nicht viel Gedanken drum machen.
Ansonsten gibt es Webframeworks wie Sand am Meer. Das würde ich eher davon abhängig machen, mit welcher Programmiersprache du im Backend arbeiten willst, was ich dann nehme.
Wenn du wirklich nur ein paar Buttons willst, dann musst du einfach plain JavaScript machen, also im Frontend.
Wenn du wirklich nur ein paar Buttons willst, dann musst du einfach plain JavaScript machen, was ich dann nehmen.
Leider ist die Rust Community auf der einen Seite cool, auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen zu radikal. Es gab ja letztens diese Riesendiskussion darüber, dass ein Maintainer von...
Rust Web Server. Ich zeige es euch mal. X. Wie hieß das Ding? GitHub. X, das da.
Der Maintainer ist da letztens zurückgetreten von diesem Web Framework. Das ist das schnellste Web Framework bzw. der schnellste Web Server, den es zurzeit so gibt in Rust.
Oder allgemein übergreifend, das ist halt in Rust programmiert. Die Leute sind ihm so sehr auf den Sack gegangen, weil er manchmal die Sache nicht so den Rust-Way gemacht hat.
Ihr müsst wissen, dass es in Rust noch mehr als in C-Sharp und.NET verpönt ist, unsaved Code zu verwenden.
Also wenn man in Rust unsaved schreibt, ist das nahe an der Gottesläste rum.
Und die Rust Community hat den Typ übelst abgefuckt, bis er irgendwann gesagt hat, ihr könnt mich mal...
Ich arbeite hier nicht mal mit, ich habe keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Richtig, genau. Support-Unic. Es war nicht exakt an allen Stellen so, wie man Rust verwenden soll.
Er hat zum Beispiel aber nur an internem Code. In internem Code hat er unsaved verwendet.
Und da haben sich die Leute auf GitHub aufgeregt, so nach dem Motto, das ist undefined behavior, Rust unsaved, das macht man nicht.
Und da hat er halt gesagt, das ist interner Code und das Ding ist schnell und es soll schnell bleiben.
Und dann hat er irgendwann keinen Bock mehr auf die Diskussion gehabt.
Na ja, man ist schon verständlich. So ein Open-Sourcing-Maintain kann schwierig sein.
An sich, Rust, die Sprache ist super. Da würde ich auch gerne mehr machen, aber ich habe da aktuell leider nicht so die Anwendungszwecke für, wo ich sage,
ah ja, da lohnt sich der Aufwand, das in Rust zu machen, weil Rust ist schon so eine Sache, wenn man nicht viel in Rust macht.
Man braucht erst mal so eine Woche, bis man wieder in der Rust-Denkweise drin ist, dass man nicht alle zwei Sekunden kompilieren muss und gucken, ob der Checker irgendwas feststellt.
Ja, Lumix kannst du machen.
PHP, Backend, Laravel wäre auch eine Option. Gibt es vieles.
Kommt darauf an, wo man die Anwendung hosten will. Wenn man die bei einem Web-Hoster hosten lassen will, dann ist PHP auch heute definitiv nicht schlecht.
Weil, egal wie billig das Hosting-Paket ist, PHP ist überall dabei.
React Native, das kann man auch machen.
Habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht?
Ich weiß nur, dass mich das als Cross-Platform Technologie nicht so angesprochen hat, weil, weil, weil, weil, genau, weil man keine ordentlichen Desktop-Apps machen kann.
Das ist ja hauptsächlich was für Mobile. Ja, es gibt, ich weiß, es gibt für Windows auch eine React-Native-Geschichte.
Aber wenn ich Desktop supporten will, dann würde ich schon gerne Linux, Windows und Mac supporten und das funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Ich will nicht wieder von Cross-Platform GUI-Frameworks anfangen und das ist nicht gescheit. Es gibt, das habe ich jetzt ja oft genug erzählt.
Microsoft soll da mal ran.
Wenn die es schaffen würden für.NET Core ein ordentlich gutes Cross-Platform GUI-Framework anzubinden, das wäre nice.
Ja, aber auf dem Desktop kannst du, ja, aber es gibt nichts. Also, wie willst du es machen?
.NET alleine macht im Alter ja kein GUI.
.NET Cross-Platform GUI gibt es nicht gescheit. Es gibt ein paar vielversprechende Projekte, sowas wie Avalonia, aber das ist noch weit davon entfernt.
Großartig, dass ich das benutzen würde.
Max, was sagst du eigentlich zu PWA-Apps mit Chrome? Kann man damit für die Zukunft bleiben?
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe.
Für mich sind PWA-Apps, wenn Apple, Apple ist ja das Problem, was PWA-Apps angeht.
Also PWA-Apps sind progressive Web-Apps. Das sind quasi Webseiten zum verlinken auf dem Startbildschirm, um es mal ganz blöd zu sagen, ganz grob zu sagen.
Und Apple ist da ein bisschen hinten dran, was PWA-Support angeht.
Unter Android ist es viel viel schöner gelöst.
Unter iOS hat man da sinnlose Restriktionen bei PWA-Apps.
Aber ich hoffe, dass sich PWA-Apps durchsetzen, weil gerade für jemanden, der keinen Bock hat, für die App-Stores zu entwickeln, sind PWA-Apps top.
Für mich kommt beispielsweise App-Store-Entwicklung insofern nicht in Frage, weil man, also bei Apple kommt man gar nicht drumherum.
Bei Android geht das, glaube ich, irgendwie, dass man keine Kohle bezahlen muss.
Bei Apple kommt man gar nicht drumherum.
Und spätestens wenn es um Code-Signing-Zertifikate geht, geht das eh, kostet es ein paar hundert Euro pro Jahr.
Apple kocht gar nicht so sehr sein eigenes Süppchen, was PWA-S angeht. Nur ein bisschen.
Aber Apple ist hinten dran mit dem Support.
Zum Beispiel gibt es viele Sachen, die in Safari funktionieren.
Allerdings, wenn man ein Webview hat, weil mein PWA ist ja nur im Prinzip nur ein Browser, der so aussieht, als wäre eine eigene Anwendung.
Viele Sachen, die Safari supportet, vor allem Audio-Video-Geschichten, gehen in einer PWA nicht.
Hat jemand einen Tipp, wie man mit Flask-Dateien an einen C-Sharp-Klein schicken kann, speichern kann?
Wenn das das Einzige ist, was du machen willst, dann mach doch einfach einen Python-Web-Server auf in dem Verzeichnis und mach einen HTTP-Get auf die Datei.
Oder muss es mit Flask sein?
Dann weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie man da statische Dateien surft.
Ich verwende Flask nicht.
Ich sehe bloß immer Beispiele und zum Einstieg sieht das super aus.
Das ist nicht Elektron für Dummies.
Das ist vor allem auf Mobile-Geräten lange Zeit die einzige Möglichkeit gewesen, so etwas ähnliches wie Apps zu vertreiben, ohne dass man in den App-Store musste.
Was sehr praktisch ist.
Leider ist Apple ein bisschen hinten dran.
Was Cross-Platform-Guys anbelangt, hoffe ich ein bisschen auf Flutter.
Allerdings, bis die es wirklich schaffen, native, gut und ordentlich und mit allen Funktionen Windows, Mac und Linux zu unterstützen, werden noch Jahre ins Land ziehen, falls das überhaupt passieren wird.
Flutter hat eindeutig Mobile im Fokus und nicht so sehr Desktop.
Das einzig brauchbare Cross-Platform-Gui-Framework ist nach wie vor Qt.
Oder eben, wenn es Web sein soll, Elektron.
Was anderes gibt es schlicht und ergreifend nicht, was sich pauschal für jede Anwendung eignet.
Ich hätte es auch gerne, wenn es etwas ordentliches gibt.
Es gibt viele vielversprechende Projekte, aber außer Qt und Elektron gibt es nichts.
PULP FEATURES PRODUCTION READY, wie man so schön sagt.
Was macht eigentlich die Heizung?
Der Brenner geht aus, Leute.
Warm Wasser ist warm gemacht, der Brenner geht aus.
Samorin mag ganz gut sein für Mobile-Apps, Cross-Platform-Gui ist nichts.
Ich weiß, dass die mal Beta-Linux-Support eingebaut haben, aber das, was ich da gesehen habe, hat mich überhaupt nicht überzeugt.
Samorin ist ja quasi eh schon ein Rapper, um Rapper, die was rappen, also ganz Rap-Gott.
Samorin selbst ist ja so ein gemeinsamer Nenner für GUI-Elemente.
Samorin malt ja nicht selbst, Samorin nimmt ja GUI-Elemente, die die jeweilige Plattform hat.
Die müssen eh schon den gemeinsamen Nenner nehmen.
Und unter Linux verwenden sie dann auch noch GTK, also sprich, die haben, die rappen nen.NET, nen outdated.NET GTK Rapper für Samorin.
Es ist für'n Arsch, es ist für'n Arsch.
Deswegen, ich bleib dabei außer Qt, wenn man C++ aushält und erträgt, bleibt da außer Elektron nicht viel zur Zeit.
Es hat schon seinen Grund, dass die meisten Cross-Platform-Anwendungen, die wirklich Cross-Platform sind, also sprich, Linux-Merke Windows, IOS und Android, dass die Elektron sind.
Eine Möglichkeit gibt es auch noch, die man jetzt mal nicht unerwähnt lassen sollte, die für mich aber nicht in Frage kommt und das ist JavaFX.
Nicht mal die Java Basics.
Ja, aber es ist doch schön, wenn dir das gefällt, ohne dass du die Java Basics raffst, weil ganz ehrlich, die Java Basics hast du auch nichts verpasst.
Nenn lieber nur ordentlich anständige Sprache.
Ja, Qt, ich hoffe auch auf Flutter. Flutter haben zumindest so die passende Firma dahinter, wobei Google-Projekte, Google-Projekte sind ja auch immer so ein Ding für sich.
Der Brenner geht da nicht mal unter 32%.
Der Brenner bleibt bei 32%.
Guck mal, es geht hoch, Leute. Temperatur.
Wir sind jetzt nur noch 1,8 Grad entfernt von der Zieltemperatur.
Wir sind fast da.
Für was braucht ihr um die Uhrzeit eigentlich noch warm Wasser? Ja, für die Heizung.
Schaltet er sich nicht ab 22? Nein, komplett ausschalten tut er nicht.
Ich glaube, der hat auch immer ein bisschen warm Wasser drin, dass wenn du mal nachts, keine Ahnung, wenn du aufstehst morgens und willst Zähne putzen oder so.
Ein bisschen warm Wasser gibt es immer.
Und Heizung, der muss ja auch die Heizung heizen.
Also der muss ja auch warm Wasser in die Heizung machen.
Standardprogramm 6 bis 22 Uhr.
Ey, wir könnten das abrufen, wie das Programm ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert, Max. Kein Schimmer.
Ich sehe auch bloß das, was ich hier sehe.
Die Temperatur geht hoch hier.
Die ist jetzt die letzte Zeit, es ist komplett die ganze Zeit gestiegen.
M15k, das kann ich nachvollziehen, aber die einzige logische Variante ist doch eigentlich, dass man seine Runtime mitbringt.
Also ich würde niemals von meinem User erwarten, dass der Java installiert.
Ich würde immer meine Runtime mitbringen.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn ich irgendeine.NET Anwendung mache.
Da würde ich auch nie den normalen Self-Contain-Build machen, sondern immer den kompletten Self-Contain-Build mit Runtime und sowas.
Mal davon abgesehen, es ist ja auch kein Ding, seine Runtime mitzubringen.
Weil ich meine, in Zeiten von Elektron-Anwendungen, die Leute haben sich daran gewöhnt, dass unter 200 MB Download keine gescheite Anwendung ist.
Und mit 200 MB oder 150 MB oder sonst was, da kannst du wahrscheinlich dreimal deine Java Runtime und dreimal.NET Core shippen.
Ich glaube, eine komplett gezippte Self-Contain.NET Anwendung ist mittlerweile 25 MB.
Wenn du Debug-Zeugs rausgemacht hast, Release-Build und unnötige Sachen entfernt hast, 25 oder 30 MB gezippt, das kann man doch mitleben.
Ich meine, ja, gut, ordentliche C-Anwendungen, dann noch ein bisschen kleiner, die ist dann wahrscheinlich nur 5 KB.
Dafür muss man es halt in C programmieren.
Ich habe es ja gesehen, diese Kamera-Überwachungssoftware, die ich da gebastelt habe, die ist ja eine Mischung aus Go und C.
Und das Ding ist glaube ich, wie groß war das am Ende, 4 MB oder so?
Und da ist alles drin, da ist alles drin, die komplette Backend-Geschichte, die ganze Recording-Funktionalität, das Web-Interface, alles drin, irgendwie in 4 oder 5 MB.
Oder waren es 8 MB, es war auf jeden Fall nicht viel.
Gibt es irgendwelche bekannten Consumer-Apps, die einen Java Runtime brauchen? Fällt mir keiner ein.
Mir fallen allgemein nicht viele Desktop-Apps ein, die auf Java basieren. Ja, Minecraft.
Also mir fallen nicht viele ein. Ja, J-Downloader, aber es gibt nicht viele, es gibt echt nicht viele.
Es gibt nicht viele. Ja, die ganzen Chat-Prains-IDEs, aber das sind ja keine normalen Anwendungen, keine Consumer-Geschichten.
Also auf dem Desktop gibt es wirklich erstaunlich wenig.
Was? Hey Max, ich hab ein Problem, meine IP-Cams bleiben nach rund 2 Stunden immer stecken. Wie bleiben denn IP-Cams stecken?
Und das Netzwerk ist dann immer voll langsam, bis ich die Fritzbox neu starte. Woran kann das liegen?
What? Sieh ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Das WLAN? WLAN-IP-Cams?
Weil wenn das WLAN ist, dann würde ich mal den Channel wechseln.
Ja, Oracle hat es verkackt. Oracle hat vieles verkackt, ja.
Ja, leider. Es wäre cool, wenn es neben Acute und Electron noch eine ordentliche Cross-Platform-GUI-Technologie geben würde.
Dann würden uns auch ein paar Electron-Anwendungen erspart bleiben.
Weil das nimmt langsam überhand. Ich mein, der Witz ist doch. Ja, guck mal. Eine publische Notiz-Anwendung.
Braucht irgendwie 350 MB RAM, wenn es einfach nur gestartet ist. Das ist doch lächerlich.
Ja, Acute ist wirklich ganz gut. Was mich an Acute halt nur ärgert ist, dass es C++ ist. Und ich hasse C++.
C++ ist die hässlichste Programmiersprache und ekligste Programmiersprache auf der Welt.
Da sind so viele Sachen fail dran, dass ich sogar ein eigenes Dokument gemacht habe, warum C++ sagt, falls mal wieder die Diskussion aufkommt.
Oh, ich glaube, das spreche ich nicht richtig aus. Was? Wie auch immer, Twitch Prime.
Wir sind fast dran. Wir haben fast die Zieltemperatur erreicht.
Was ist deine Meinung zu funktionalen Programmiersprachen wie Haskell? Ich finde es super, dass es das Ganze gibt.
Das ist etwas, mit dem ich mich schon lange näher beschäftigen will.
Außer ganz, ganz bisschen F-Sharp und ein bisschen was funktionales. Mittlerweile ist die F-Sharp auch, hat auch ein paar funktionale Sachen dabei. Aber so ein bisschen Basics in Rust und Go, die auch teilweise ein bisschen funktional sind, habe ich keine Ahnung davon.
Also Haskell, F-Sharp, kannst du mich davor setzen und ich checke nichts.
Ich dachte immer, deutsche Interpretationen wären das langweiligste, das es gibt, aber Cisco Theorieunterricht übertrifft alles.
Ja, das kann schon hardcore langweilig sein, wenn du einfach nur Leute hast, die frontal Ansprache machen.
Eines, was man sich bei Cisco merken muss, die nennen alles anders als der Rest. Zum Beispiel sowas zu wie Bound und Trunk Ports und so. Die nennen alles, alles immer ein bisschen anders.
Finde C++ nicht schlecht, zeig das Dokument. Nee, ich muss in 5 Minuten auf, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Ich meine, allein schon, also eine Sache kann ich sagen, allein schon, dass es in der C++ Standardlib keine Methode gibt, einen String von klein geschrieben, also ohne jetzt da irgendwie 2, 3, 4 Zeilen schreiben zu müssen,
dass man keinen einfachen String-Methode toUpper, dass das Ding keine Möglichkeit hat, toUpper zu machen, dass es in C++, in der Standardlib nichts gibt, keine fertige Methode, die einfach den String von klein zu groß macht.
Ich weiß, was man machen kann, man kann den String anlegen, man kann Transform drauf machen oder man kann eine Schleife machen oder sonst was, aber warum ist solche absolute Basic Funktionalität nicht dabei?
Schreibt man nicht in einer Zeile. Du musst auf jeden Fall einmal den String anlegen und dann Transform, oder du machst den String inline, aber du brauchst auf jeden Fall schonmal 2.
Und die sind hässlich, die sind hässlich, ich meine ernsthaft, ich hab's ja hier.
Pass mal auf, das hier ist in C++ wie ich einen String groß mache.
Das da, was ist mit den C++ Standard Leuten los?
Warum, warum, warum so was für einen String groß machen? Warum? So was beknarktes.
Warum gibt es nicht, ganz, ganz will ich sagen, warum gibt es nicht sowas?
Na gut, das klappt jetzt nicht, das ist, warum gibt es nicht wenigstens, warum gibt es nicht wenigstens sowas?
Ich mein, String to Upper, das ist eines der häufigsten, am häufigsten verwendetsten Operationen wahrscheinlich auf allen Stringklassen dieser Welt.
Und selbst wenn man das nicht so machen will, weil man sagt, ja man möchte das irgendwie damit die Stringklasse nicht bloaten oder was auch immer, dann soll man sich was schöneres ausdenken als das da.
Ich mein, what the fuck, was ist mit dem C++ Standard Gremium los? Was ist das für ne Wurst?
Ja, also ich hab mir noch mehr so Sachen aufgeschrieben, weil die Diskussionen immer, immer anfangen mit C++. Es sind so viel ekliche Sachen.
Ja, das geht mit, das geht mit den C++ Lambda Syntax, geht das weiter?
Ich mein, wer hat sich, oh fuck, ich krieg die, wer hat sich das hier ausgedacht, Alter?
Was?
Wollten die ein Wettbewerb gewinnen, wer kann die meisten Klammern aneinander setzen?
Was dazu kommt, dass man noch nicht mal, also wenn, wenn irgendeine Funktion, ne, ne, ne, auch ne Lambda als Argument verträgt,
dann kann ich anstatt des Lambdas, kann ich da ne, ne, ne Plain-C-Funktion reinstecken, wenn die Parameter stimmen.
Aber eine C++ Klassenmethode kann ich aus der Klasse selbst draußen nicht reinstecken. Total, total wirr.
Also sieh ich ja ein ganzer Stream an Content. Oh ne, da muss ich mich aber aufregen.
Und allein schon, das Schlimmste an C++, was hat die eigentlich geritten, dass die immer noch mit Header-Dateien rumfuhrwerken, ey?
Keine irgendwie halbwegs moderne Sprache fuddelt noch mit Header-Dateien rum.
Man könnte so langsam aber sicher auch mal im Jahr 2020 ankommen.
Ich denke, es kommt alles auf Performance zurück.
Dann guck dir Rust an. Unter Rust sind die Sachen, die eingebaut sind, wirklich erstklassig gemacht.
Rust ist auch ätzend zu programmieren, aber auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise, wie es C++ ist.
In Rust ist alles logisch, soweit es geht.
Das Ding hat ein ordentliches Paketmanager dabei.
Das Ding braucht keine komischen Rumgewurschteln mit Header-Dateien.
Dafür ist Rust halt an anderer Stelle nervig.
Aber eigentlich nur, weil man selbst zu unfähig ist, Rust zu programmieren.
Es ist komplett andere Art und Weise nervig, wie C++.
Paketmanager gibt es nix.
C++ hat Enums, Enums zu einem String geht nicht.
Ranges sind für'n Arsch. Es gibt fünf Varianten, wie man Iterator macht.
Dann gibt es solche Konstrukte hier.
Dann gibt es solche Konstrukte. Sowas geht nur in C++.
Das ist überhaupt valid syntax.
Das macht auch noch was Sinnvolles.
Was andermalig nicht geht.
Wenn ich sowas sehe...
Was ist mit dem C++ Standard-Credit los?
Was machen die?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Wenn ich nachts aufs Klo muss, ist das was rauskommt.
Das kommt dabei raus.
Also in die Schüssel kommt das raus.
C++ ist mit Abstand die hässlichste und nervigste Programmiersprache überhaupt.
Was das macht...
Ich glaube, das splittet von einem Template.
Templates sind die Generics von C++.
Das splittet die Argumente auf.
Das, was man in C-Sharp mit Params macht...
Wenn man sowas in C-Sharp schreibt, sprich, dass es beliebig viele Argumente geben kann,
vom Typ String, macht das in C++.
Weil C++ keine Params kann.
In C++ ist es auch nicht möglich, obwohl C++ super huge objektorientiert ist,
in C++ ist es nicht möglich, zur Runtime festzustellen, welche Klasse ein Objekt hat.
Natürlich in der Welt der C++-Programmierer gibt es dieses Problem nicht,
weil man das ja alles zur Compile-Zeit schon macht.
Bis auf die Fälle, wo man das nicht zur Compile-Zeit macht.
Ja, C++...
Ok Leute, letzter Blick auf die Heizung.
Der Brenner brennt immer noch auf 32%.
Alternative zu C++.
Ja, wie immer, kommt drauf an, was man machen muss.
C?
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Wenn es ein bisschen high-leveliger sein darf, kann ich auf jeden Fall mittlerweile.NET Core empfehlen.
Ist zwar vom Anwendungszweck her nicht wirklich das, wofür man C++ verwendet.
Wenn man ein bisschen mehr Ressourcen verbrauchen kann und ein bisschen größere Binaries klarkommt
und ein bisschen mehr aufhört, dann ist.NET und C-Sharp auf jeden Fall eine super Alternative.
Du kannst einfach C verwenden, das ist alle mal besser als C++.
Oder wenn du was Neues verwenden willst, nimmst du Rust.
Das Schöne an Rust ist, dass der Interop mit C total einfach ist.
Interop mit C++ kann der C++ selber noch nicht mehr richtig.
Das ist kein Witz.
C++ ist selbst mit C++ nicht kompatibel.
In Rust kannst du super easy C-Interop machen.
Du kannst immer entsprechend die ganzen C-Libraries verwenden, wenn du was brauchst.
Oder halt Betriebssystemaufrufe, was auch immer.
Also Rust ist auch eine gute Alternative.
Oder aber, wenn du ein bisschen in die, vielleicht ein Ticken mehr funktionale Richtung,
aber nur ein Ticken mehr, ist nicht wirklich funktional.
Und Static Binary Summels, dann nimmst du Go.
Es gibt viele Alternativen.
C++ braucht man heute eigentlich hauptsächlich an den Stellen,
wenn die existierenden Sachen drum herum schon C++ sind.
Zum Beispiel Microcontroller, Arduino Zeug ist halt C++.
Wobei die meisten mehr C-Style schreiben als C++.
Qt ist halt C++, da kommst du halt nicht drum herum.
Wenn das Framework und die Tools und alles C++ ist, dann musst du halt auch selbst C++.
Aber ansonsten, oder wenn man Unreal irgendwelche Gamegeschichten,
wenn die halt in C++ sind, dann musst du Erweiterungen eben halt auch in C++ machen.
Aber ansonsten, äh, Riesenbogen um C++ machen.
Warum haust du eigentlich immer eins in die Loads-Jacht?
Genau, das hat ja schon einer, das hat ja schon einer
den passenden Kommando gepostet.
Also eins muss man sagen, abends wird die Heizung wärmer als mittags, was merkwürdig ist.
Aber man muss sagen, heute haben wir gut Progress gemacht, oder?
Wir haben unseren Prometheus-Heizung-Exporter gebastelt.
Wir haben das Ganze probiert, eingerichtet in Prometheus in Krafana.
Zumindest weiß ich jetzt, wie es geht.
Und wir haben uns viel anderes Zeug angeguckt.
Ja, überall wo C++ verbreitet, es hat keiner Bock drauf C++ zu programmieren,
die machen das halt gezwungenermaßen.
Es ist genauso wie im Bankbereich, ich kenn das ja bei uns, im Finanzbereich,
Kobol noch verwendet wird.
Bei uns hatten sie letztens einen Big Brain Plan,
sie wollten sich einen Kobol zu Java-Tool kaufen
und ihr Kobol in Java umwandeln.
Hat aber glaube ich nicht so gut funktioniert.
Und dann kam einer auf die Idee, lass uns doch irgendwie eine
Kobol-VM auf Java-Basis oder irgendwie so kaufen.
Und das hat aber auch nicht funktioniert.
Jetzt bleibt es weiterhin Kobol in Kobol auf Kobol.
So Leute, ich werde dann mal ins Bett gehen
und wir sehen uns, macht's gut.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.